I now have the honor to give the floor
to Mr Forker Turk High Commissioner for
human rights to make a statement via
video message
Mr President Excellence is distinguished
colleagues
four years ago the people of Sudan lit a
Beacon of Hope for Millions around the
world on 11 April 2019 popular protests
brought an end to Decades of tyranny and
human rights violations toppling the
long-standing dictatorship of omara
Bashir women and young people were at
the Forefront demanding good governance
and a new social contract between the
state and the People based on Democracy
freedom justice and a fair share of
development this inspiring movement was
followed by significant reforms but the
hoped for transition to full civilian
Rule and democracy was once again dashed
in October 21 when General al-buhan and
General de gallo jointly carried out a
military coup
last month fighting exploded between the
forces led by those same two men
plunging this much suffering country
into catastrophe since in April at least
487 civilians have been killed notably
in Khartoum Argentina Nyala and elopid
the real figure is much higher more than
154 000 people have fled the country and
an estimated 700 700 000 more have been
displaced inside the borders of Sudan
those who remain in areas affected by
the conflict are at continued severe
risk in her tomb clashes between the two
Armed Forces shelling and airstrikes
have taken place in heavily populated
presidential areas and millions of
people are now struggling to access food
Fuel and currency
in parts of the four as well as the Blue
Nile and cordovan regions the violence
between military groups has triggered
inter-ethnic clashes in westerf war at
least 100 people have been killed and
thousands displaced by inter-commune
violence between so-called Arab and
masalit groups Allied respectively with
the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese armed forces the country's
health system has been severely damaged
with at least 17 attacks against health
facilities and several others occupied
by military forces people who have been
wounded women in childbirth are simply
the severely ill have nowhere to go
years of development efforts are being
obliterated by damage to water
electricity and Communications
infrastructure
extensive and increasing Looting of un
and international NGO offices businesses
and private property have also
obstructed the humanitarian operations
that kept millions of people alive and
in health
wfp projects that if the conflict
continues 2.5 million more people could
become acutely food insecure within
three to six months bringing the total
to 19 million people more than half the
population already some 50 000 acutely
malnourished children have been cut off
from receiving life-saving treatment
according to Archer I strongly condemn
this wanton violence in which both sides
has trampled International humanitarian
law notably the principles of
Distinction proportionality and
precaution
the Sudanese military has launched a tax
intensely occupied civilian areas
including airstrikes last week one
airstrike reportedly hit the vicinity of
a hospital in the East Nile area of
Khartoum killing several civilians the
rsf meanwhile has allegedly taken over
numerous buildings in Khartoum to use as
operational bases evicting residents and
launching attacks from densely inhabited
urban areas these tactics Place
civilians at acute risk and prevent
people from accessing critical supplies
and assistance
we've also received several reports
alleging Sexual Violence by uniformed
men as well as allegations of unlawful
killings and enforced disappearances
Mr President six months ago I visited
Sudan it was my first mission as U.N
High Commissioner for human rights at
that pivot to a moment in the country's
history with talks underway to shape a
transition to fully Democratic civilian
government I expressed my solidarity
with the people of Sudan and I needed to
bring a strong message
accountability and human rights must be
at the core of any future agreement in
the course of that visit I met both
General alcohol and general tagalo among
many others I urged them and all those
who were involved in the talks to focus
on accountability for past human rights
violations and on the common good
today immense damage has been done
destroying the hopes and rights of
millions of people it is essential that
both parties
urgently commit to an inclusive
political process and to negotiated
peace the ongoing talks in Jetta which
focus on creating a ceasefire need to be
complemented by commitments to establish
a humanitarian truth to enable
life-saving deliveries of Aid to allow
for safe passage for civilians from
areas of hostilities and to protect
humanitarian supplies from looting it is
also crucial that discussions expand to
respecting International humanitarian
law protecting civilians and bringing an
end to human rights violations
to date despite intense diplomatic
efforts notably by the African Union the
intergovernmental Authority and
development the league of Arab states
and the United Nations the leaders of
the saf and rsf have not agreed to
discuss ending their hostilities
we have been moved by the courage and
resilience of the people of Sudan the
desire for Change and their attachment
to principles of justice and freedom
they and their country are pivotal to
the future of Africa at the point where
the two Niles blue and white surged into
one Majestic River it is impossible not
to see how profoundly connected is the
continent and how powerfully its
resources could drive growth and peace
for millions of people
I condemn the use of Violence by
individuals who have no regard for the
lives and fundamental rights of millions
of Their Own compatriots all parties
must protect the rights of citizens and
comply with International humanitarian
and human rights law if there is one
lesson to be drawn from this tragic
crisis it is the pressing need for all
transitional arrangements to build on
Bedrock commitments to accountability
non-discrimination and participation so
that peace can be sustainable and stable
because it is just
Mr President the Human Rights Council
has called this special session to
express its urgent concern for the
rights and lives of Sudan's people
I take this opportunity to urge all
states with influence in the region to
encourage by all possible means the
resolution of this crisis
in closing I pay tribute to my staff
notably our national staff who have been
directly affected by the fighting and
severe shortages
thanks and I express my deepest and most
heartfelt solidarity with the people of
Sudan thank you
I thank you Mr High Commissioner
now let me give the floor to miss tanang
mofo King chair of the Coordination
Committee of special procedures and
she's going to join us via Zoom Madam we
have the floor
so today on behalf of the Coordination
Committee of special procedures we
welcome the deciding to convince special
session of the human rights impact on
the ongoing conflict in the Sudan as
shown by The Joint statement issued this
morning by several mandate holders
including myself special procedures have
followed the evolving situation in the
country closely and express serious
concerns about the plight of the
Sudanese people
the situation of human rights in Sudan
has actually been under the radar of
special procedures for many years
especially of successive country minute
holders from 1993 to 2020
the crisis in the Sudan sparked by the
clashes between the rapid support forces
and the sugar news Armed Forces has now
extended Beyond three weeks throughout
this period innocent women men girls and
boys have borne the severe consequences
of the conflict enduring immense
hardship and remaining exposed to
significant protection risks and the
situation remains deeply distressing and
demands urgent attention and action
since the onset of hostilities an
alarming number of lives have been lost
with hundreds perishing and thousands
sustaining injuries tragically including
children the dire consequences of this
crisis have compelled hundreds of
thousands of individuals to seek Refuge
While others have been forcibly
displaced from their homes
regrettably Sudan is surveillance in
search of safety of safety reportedly
have found themselves subjected to a
gregarious human rights violations
including sexual and gender-based
violence and deprived of vital
Necessities such as food water
Healthcare including reproductive Health
Fuel and other basic Commodities
moreover the breakdown in communication
Services has added to the distressing
predicament faced by those affected
I miss this turmoil numerous individuals
find themselves trapped within densely
populated residential areas of khatum
Bari or majuman as well as Townsend the
four and Northern cordovan
with the absence of electricity and the
scarcity of Health Care and essential
services and the depiction of food water
and medical supplies they can cannot
confront an uncertain future as a direct
consequence of the ongoing ongoing
conflict
of particular concern is also the safety
and well-being of women and children
people with disabilities and older
persons as families escape from
hostilities they face the distressing
reality of being torn apart which raises
the likelihood of exposing them to
severe human rights violations such as
enforced disappearances
moreover the ability to Monitor and
document the situation on the ground has
been significantly hindered due to the
targeting of journalists as well as the
intimidation and threats faced by human
rights Defenders particularly women
human rights defenders in the floor and
cartoon this situation has resulted in
an information blackout
Mr President prior to this crisis the
Sudan already had 3.7 million internally
displaced persons within that country
tragically the delivery of critically
needed food assistance vital
infrastructure and life-saving services
has been subjected to what appear to be
deliberate and indiscriminate attacks
posing a grave threat to the
humanitarian Personnel including local
health care workers impeding their
efforts despite the dedicated work of
humanitarian organizations to expand
their operations the persistent
conflicts severely hampers access to
essential Provisions including food and
other necessities
urgent and decisive measures are
imperative to tackle the worsening
crisis we need to protect the rights and
well-being of vulnerable people and
rehabilitate critical infrastructure and
services these actions are crucial in
guaranteeing unhindered access to health
care and ensuring the Safety and
Security of all individuals affected by
the crisis
Mr President as stressed in the
statement issued by special procedures
yesterday on the present situation
we urgently implored the conflicting
parties to seize all hostilities without
delay thereby de-escalating the volatile
circumstances and creating an
environment conducive to the resumption
of unhindered and comprehensive
humanitarian operations this crucial
step is Paramount in alleviating the
immense suffering insured injured by
affected individuals ensuring provision
of life-saving protection to those in
dire need and a pathway to sustainable
development we urge the conflict in
parties to uphold their responsibilities
according to international law ensuring
the safety of civilians and vital
civilian infrastructure such as schools
and hospitals it is crucial for them to
publicly commit to safeguarding
humanitarian Personnel facilities and
resources thereby ensuring unrestricted
access to Aid and assistance
we recognize the efforts of neighboring
countries and urge all states to
maintain open borders allowing the entry
of individual seeking Refuge not to
return any Sudanese presently abroad and
to provide adequate protection and
humanitarian Aid to those who are
fleeing in Sudan including those who are
already internally displaced within
Sudan before the escalation
additionally we call all upon states to
allocate resources to the neighboring
countries assisting them in
accommodating the influx of people who
are resulting from the Sudanese conflict
finally we urge the immediate initiation
of independent and impartial
investigations into the loss of Civilian
lives injuries sustained by individuals
and cases of ill treatment and other
gross human rights violations inflicted
upon humanitarian Personnel healthcare
workers human rights Defenders
journalists as well as attacks on
civilian infrastructure
special procedures are ready to work
with this Council the High Commissioner
and its designated expert to continue
monitoring and providing advice to
address and improve the situation on the
ground I thank you Mr President
thank you madam first statement
colleagues let me indicate that the list
of speakers is now closed and we will
now hear from the country concerned so
let me give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Sudan
Ambassador you have five minutes and you
have the floor
microphone please
foreign
thank you Mr President
at the outset I would like to convey my
condolences to all those who fall in
victims of the military confrontation in
my country since the rebellion of the
rsf on the 15th of April and wishing
quick recovery to the victims
allow me at the outside to describe
what's happening in Sudan the
integration of rsf and the national Army
the Sudanese Armed Forces was one of the
main challenges of the transitional
period specially after the signing of
the Juba peace agreement on the 3rd of
October 2020 and the integration of
armed groups in the Army according to
the protocol of security arrangements
and the principle of the one National
Army as it is the case in all the
countries of the world however
unfortunately the issue of integration
has been constantly postponed until it
exploded on the 15th of April uh
when a cartoon woke up to witness a full
military attack by Rebel forces on all
strategic facilities and cartoon namely
headquarters of the Army hospital
Hospitality House the headquarters of
the president of the sovereignty Council
airport radio and TV headquarters
and uh parallel with attacks to all
other airports and vital facilities and
other governorates what's happening in
Sudan is an internal Affair and what the
saf are doing as a constitutional duty
to all armies and all the countries of
the world I repeat what the Sudanese
armed forces are doing as a
constitutional duty to all armies of all
the countries of the world we thank your
Council for its close follow-up and
interest in what's happening in Sudan
however we reiterate that our position
vis-a-vis this ad hoc session and any
session sorry and any consequences is
based on the following first
the absolute priority of our government
to Human Rights promotion and protection
however and under the dire circumstances
that we are witnessing namely in the
capital cartoon and the military clashes
and the falling of victims and the
wounded persons we have a priority which
is to achieve a ceasefire to save lives
this is our priority and this is in line
with the universal declaration for human
rights which turned the right into the
right to life as a priority uh followed
by all other tracks second there are
Regional efforts underway
to achieve a ceasefire and the truth so
you have followed the
negotiations underway in under the
Blessed initiative of the brotherly
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and the United
States of America before that the
initiative by igado which had asked
their excellencies the president of
South Sudan Djibouti and Kenya to go to
Sudan and to engage in these
negotiations it is an initiative which
is supported by the African Union and
the quad comprising Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia United Arab Emirates USA and the
UK this is a positive initiative which
is in line with the principle of African
solutions for African problems that's
why Mr President we are asking to allow
us more time a greater opportunity to
this and Regional efforts without
overcoming them or negatively impacting
them third
since the Rebellion by the rsf on the
15th of April the issue of Sudan is
still under consideration before the
security Council given that it's the
entity in charge of preserving
International Peace and security so far
three sessions have been held by the
security Council
regarding Sudan the latest being one
held yesterday the issue of Sudan is
still under consideration before the
security Council first the issue of
Sudan is on the agenda of the Human
Rights Council there was a session due
to be held in next junior next June
during the 53rd session we have less
than three weeks depending the holding
of the upcoming session on Sudan why are
you rushing to hold such an adult
session in this timing especially that
it has not received the support of any
African or Arab countries which are our
groups of direct belonging Mr President
protecting and promoting human rights
has always been and will always remain
as part of the priorities of our
government this is a very important
National agenda not only prerequisites
that are imposed on us to implement the
international human rights Mr President
regarding the human rights mechanisms
that are president in Sudan let me
enumerate them first of all the ohchr
office established based on an agreement
with the Sudanese government
three or five minutes
with the list of speakers
and allow me to recall that the speaking
time limits is 2 minutes and 30 seconds
for council members and one minute and
30 seconds for Observer States and other
observers and I thank you very much for
understanding that do that the rules are
applicable to everyone
starting with the list of speakers for
member states of the console let me give
the floor to the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland right
honorable Andrew Mitchell MP minister of
State for development in Africa by a
zoom
thank you Mr President today we
are solidarity with the people of Sudan
when the late Kofi Annan proposed the
creation of this Council he asked for a
body that could react in the very worst
moments the council that would respond
quickly so we could help save lives
since the 15th of April Sudan has
descended rapidly into crisis hundreds
of civilians have been killed thousands
injured humanitarian actors murdered the
risk of violence and atrocities against
particular groups is rising Millions
more face shortages of food and medicine
or have been forced to flee as refugees
the Secretary General has warned that
the effects of the wider region will be
very severe indeed but there is an
alternative to conflict killing for the
suffering of totally innocent and
blameless people despite the military
Takeover in 2021 Sudan had been on the
path to democratic civilian rule it was
working with the UN Human Rights system
to build domestic institutions and it
was making progress surely we must
revert to the political track so
important and so evident on April the
11th dear colleagues let us be the
Council of Mr anand's Vision let's do
all we can to help Sudan return to that
part of peace and let's do it now we
must send a United message of concern
and of horror about the increase in
human rights violations and abuses since
the outbreak of the conflict we must use
our Collective influence to break the
cycle of impunity in Sudan which only
leads to further violence there must be
accountability for the horrific events
taking place Mr President I would like
to express my appreciation for all those
working tirelessly with the parties in
Sudan to end the violence colleagues
from the African Union the
intergovernmental Authority on
development the Arab League and United
Nations
virtually the entire cohort of the
International Community it is vital
these efforts continue to colleagues in
the council I urge you to adopt today's
draft resolution to express our United
support for the human rights of the
Sudanese people and to work together for
a swift end to this terrible conflict
thank you
thank you Mr Minister and now we will
continue with Lebanon speaking on behalf
of group of Arab states
thank you president I have the honor of
making this statement on behalf
the half dates
the group is following with great
concern the development of the situation
in Sudan and we stand in solidarity with
the people of Sudan as they go through
these difficult times
our group attaches great importance to
the cease fire
and to the provision of humanitarian Aid
and we welcome all International and
Regional initiatives aimed at ending the
conflict the latest being negotiations
in Jabba in the context of the Saudi and
american-led initiative of course we
call on all of the parties in Sudan to
encourage the dialogue to achieve a
comprehensive political solution in
order to tackle the challenges and
ensure a democratic transition and
achieve the rule of law of course we
encourage dialogue and the fact of
sending
messages that encourage reconciliation
between the parties and strengthen
stability during the transition period
are all beneficial in particular we
recommend free
elections under International
observation and with full respect for
the territorial Integrity the
independence
and political ownership of South Sudan
we stand in solidarity of Sudan for this
is the affected country and of course
Sudan
as the affected country has a right for
its views to be taken into account by
the council before new mechanisms are
established or before the Mandate of
existing mandates is extended we regret
that the draft resolution
includes wording and issues which this
Council has not had the time to debate
yet and which would warrant an in-depth
examination
at greater time we urge the Bureau of
the council
to
provide all necessary assistance to
Sudan
in order to
help it along the way to ensuring
respect for human rights thank you thank
you Sweden on behalf of the European
Union
Mr President the European Union is
Gravely concerned about the human rights
situation in Sudan the impact of the
conflict not least on women children and
persons already in vulnerable situations
including increased level of stbv is
deeply concerning humanitarian needs are
at an all-time high and are expected to
increase the political crisis and
continued fighting have drastically
reduced the options for an operational
response to these growing needs for
these reasons all EU member states
supported the request for this session
the EU strongly condemns the fighting
between Sudanese armed forces and the
rapid support forces with which
fundamentally threatens the Safety and
Security of the people of Sudan as well
as the unity and stability of the
country and the region we appeal to all
parties to silence the guns immediately
and hostilities without preconditions
and fully abide by ceasefire efforts we
call on All actors to protect civilians
and refrain from attacks on civilian
infrastructure including schools
Healthcare facilities and humanitarian
warehouses international human rights
law nihl must be respected the EU calls
on All actors to allow and facilitate
Rapid Safe and unimpeded humanitarian
access as well as to protect civilians
especially children and ensure the
safety of humanitarians medical and also
diplomatic Personnel ensuring their
safety is the responsibility of the
authorities the fighting must end to
guarantee their protection and allow
space for inclusive dialogue and
mediation the EU welcomes and supports
all efforts for dialogue and mediation
in order to end the current conflict and
facilitate a return to to the return to
the path of democracy including those of
the UN Au egad the league of Arab states
as well as initiatives by Saudi Arabia
and the U.S and South Sudan all efforts
must be must respect the aspirations of
the people in Sudan for a peaceful
stable and Democratic future with
respect for human rights and the rule of
law external actors must refrain from
fueling the conflict the EU fully
supports the work of the Ohr and the
designated expert in Sudan the EU
reaffirms its steadfast support and
solidarity with the people of Sudan who
led the peaceful revolution in 2019 and
whose aspirations remain critical even
under such duress I thank you
thank you and now let me invite Finland
on behalf of a group of countries
Finland
Mr President I have the honor to deliver
this statement on behalf of the Nordic
and Baltic countries we call on the
Sudanese armed forces and the rapid
support forces to immediately stop
violence and hostilities commit to to a
ceasefire and return to a peaceful
dialogue with full respect for human
rights law and international
humanitarian law
we call on the parties to allow and
facilitate immediate return to full and
unimpeded humanitarian access and for
civilians to move safely
as reporting on great violations and
abuses of human rights in Sudan is
increasing we underline the impact of
the conflict on civilians especially
women children and persons in vulnerable
situations such as persons with
disabilities we are concerned over
sexual and gender-based violence and the
negative impacts of on upholding sexual
reproductive health and rights the
neighboring countries of Sudan have
taken on life-saving work in hosting the
hundreds of thousands of persons who
have left the country
the longer the conflict continues the
more detrimental its impacts will be on
everyone particularly children according
to UNICEF at least 9 190 children have
been killed and more than 1 700 injured
thus far furthermore access to
life-saving health services including
vaccination programs as well as to water
and sanitation services and to nutrition
is jeopardized we urge all parties to
the conflict to do their utmost to
protect children these children are the
future of the country finally we welcome
the strengthening of the Mandate of the
designated expert and the ohch are as
proposed in the resolution
accountability for violations and abuses
of international human rights law and
violations of international humanitarian
law remains crucial I thank you
thank you and now let me in my Oman
speaking on behalf of Gulf cooperation
Council
aside rice president
I am making this statement on behalf of
the states of the gulf Corporation
Council the GCC uh
following with great concern the
development of the situation in Sudan
and Western in solidarity with the
Sudanese people in these unprecedented
and difficult circumstances we call for
calm and for restraint and we call for
dialogue and the voice of reason to
Prevail we need a peaceful dialogue to
ensure political stability and allow for
economic recovery we commend the
negotiations taking place in Jeddah to
the initiative of the U.S and Saudi
Arabia with a view to
achieving a truce and a ceasefire
in coordination with the Troika and the
Quattro
and iged
the goal is also to facilitate the
supply of humanitarian Aid we also
welcome Regional initiatives aimed at
whether in crisis and restoring
political stability and security the
countries of the GCC would like to
reiterate how important it is to
preserve the state's cohesiveness and
that of its institutions and to respond
to the aspirations of the Sudanese
people we call on the International
Community to encourage dialogue
and political consensus between all
stakeholders and to
reinforce stability during the
transition period as regards the members
of the Human Rights Council we called on
them to reaffirm and respect the
sovereignty territorial integrity and
political independence of Sudan Sudan
should take political ownership of the
process and its consent is essential
before any mechanisms whatever they may
be are established by way of conclusion
the GCC States will continue to support
Sudan through humanitarian Aid and
relief operations and evacuation
operations and we welcome the Swift
humanitarian Aid provided by other
states and international organizations
as well we call for international
efforts to be stepped up to continue
medical and humanitarian assistance so
as to meet the needs on the ground and
ensure that the situation does not
deteriorate any further we also
emphasize the importance of technical
assistance provided by the Bureau of the
high commissioner's office to promote
human rights in the country thank you
and the next speaker on my list is
Germany
thank you Mr President High Commissioner
Germany aligns itself to the EU
statement
as we convene here in Geneva today the
human rights of the people of Sudan are
violated
innocent women children and men are
running out of water and food are left
without access to health care and they
are losing their lives
International humanitarian law is
repeatedly broken and I do thank the
High Commissioner for his clear words in
this room today
it is very clear human rights also apply
in times of conflict and international
humanitarian law must be respected
this is why together with the core group
we have called for this special session
the higher number of states supporting
today's session proves one thing the
International Community is steadfast in
its support of the people of Sudan and
their struggle for Freedom peace and
justice
we do support all initiatives to restore
peace peace is urgently needed
but let me say one thing also very
clearly lasting peace and the respect
for human rights go hand in hand the
conflict is jeopardizing the Safety and
Security of the Sudanese people the
stability of the country and the region
the humanitarian situation is appalling
there is a clear risk of further
escalation of the conflict with even
more grave impacts for civilians and
Germany therefore urges all sides to
immediately cease fire protect civilians
and refrain from attacks on civilian
infrastructure access for humanitarian
help is urgently needed
in 2019 the people of Sudan stood up
they toppled a dictatorship and ever
since have peacefully been frightening
for a peaceful future fighting for
peaceful future for Sudan
two generals are crushing this
aspiration right now and Germany urges
to step back from the brink and set
Sudan back on tracks towards the
civilian-led democratic government
Germany therefore supports the efforts
of the UN the African Union I got as
well as the U.S Saudi Initiative for
dialogue and mediation in pursuit of a
return for a civilian-led transition
peace and stability
today is the moment for us here in
Geneva to act the resolution is a call
for peace for human rights let us join
hands together and vote in favor of
Peace of the this resolution we owe it
to the people of Sudan and let me invite
Ukraine
thank you Mr president Ukraine is deeply
concerned with the developments in the
Sudan in the wake of a serious outbreak
of conflict which has already left
hundreds of civilians dead and thousands
wounded the escalation of violence
across the country since 15 April has
aggravated the ready hazardous
humanitarian situation according to
Orchard humanitarian needs have reached
record levels The Continuous attacks on
medical and humanitarian facilities and
staff have endangered humanitarian
operations dozens of settlements have
been destroyed and thousands of people
have been internally and externally
displaced Access to Health Care
continues to be severely impacted by the
conflict my government has evacuated
more than 100 ukrainians as as well as
Third Country Nationals from the Sudan
in the conditions of incessant fighting
no electricity scares food water and
Medicine
discipline human rights situation in
this Sudan needs urgent attention by the
International Community including this
Council
we Echo the relevant messages of concern
made by U.N Secretary General Yoon High
Commissioner for human rights
and Council special procedures
the parties must Implement an immediate
ceasefire and allow the humanitarian
access without preconditions violence
intimidation harassment of the Sudanese
people must be stopped open petrators
must be brought to account we call upon
All actors in This Sudan to take
immediate actions to restore respect for
human rights and humanitarian law to
refrain from further violations assaults
and abuses and to begin a dialect to
resolve the crisis we support all
relevant International mediating
mediation efforts in this regard Ukraine
underlies the importance of the
council's proper response to the
evolving humanoid situation in the Sudan
and fully supports the draft resolution
under consideration this Council action
is needed to put an end to the
sufferings of the Sudanese people who
crave for a just peace I thank you
thank you and now let me invite Paraguay
Russia
condolences in light of the situation
and the 500 deaths that have occurred in
recent days we would also like to
express our concern at the deterioration
of the human rights situation in Sudan
once again it is the civilian population
that is bearing the brunt especially in
light of the indiscriminate use of
explosive weapons in urban areas that
have cost the lives of civilians and
damaged infrastructure and left Millions
without access to essential goods and
services therefore we call on all
parties involved to work hard in order
to immediately cease the violence and
above all to respect the life of
civilians and cease the use of
indiscriminate weapons in populated
urban areas we urge the authorities of
Sudan to honor their commitments and
fulfill their duty of protecting
people's lives and to ensure the Swift
carrying out of transparent objective
and impartial investigations when the
time comes president over the last few
weeks Sudan has shown that there is need
to
strengthen International scrutiny over
the situation in the ground and it is
essential to adopt measures to deter
violations against the civilian
population and to ensure that the
perpetrators are brought to Justice the
serious situation described both by the
Secretary General and by the High
Commissioner Mr took have driven my
delegation to supporting the convening
of this special session on the
understanding that this council is the
appropriate space for tackling reports
of human rights violations we believe
that the African Union also has a role
to play in this difficult situation and
that other un agencies will also do the
job that falls to them such as the
security Council
we must ensure that there are concrete
responses that are provided to help the
victims of human rights violations who
continue to wait for a response from the
International Community finally
president Paraguay is confident that the
mechanisms established by the universal
human rights system has the necessary
tools for achieving the goals for which
we States agreed to establish this Human
Rights Council thank you very much
foreign thank you and now I would like
to invite Argentina
thank you president the UN Secretary
General and its special representative
as well as the High Commissioner for
human rights and the UN agencies the
icrc
have all been very clear in expressing
their concern about the human rights and
humanitarian situation in Sudan they
report attacks by the warring parties
against civilians and civil
infrastructure including schools and
hospitals this has led to desperate
shortages of food water electricity Fuel
and limited access to Medical Care
against this backdrop we are concerned
by the thousands of wounded and hundreds
of dead the increase in the levels of
sexual and gender-based violence
restrictions imposed by the warring
parties on humanitarian Aid and attacks
against humanitarian workers we are also
concerned by the attacks against
installations and members of
international organizations as well as
civil society organizations and the
Diplomatic Community such violence must
cease immediately and we urge all
parties to the conflict to fully respect
human rights and international
humanitarian law and to allow immediate
and unhindered access for humanitarian
Aid and to protect civilians Sudan as a
member of the Human Rights Council has
the obligation to maintain the highest
standards of promotion and protection
for human rights
we urge the government of Sudan to
continue and strengthen its cooperation
with the human rights expert in Sudan
with the African Union with the
intergovernmental Authority for
development the African Commission on
human rights and the rights of peoples
and the league of Arab states as well as
the special procedures of the human
rights councils and all UN treaty bodies
we urge the parties to the conflict to
immediately cease hostilities to abide
by a ceasefire and to return to the
physician process of transitioning to a
civilian-led government it is vital to
contribute to ensuring that this Council
has all the requisite elements for
providing assistance to Sudan and
helping Sudan to comply with his
International humanitarian and human
rights obligations which is one of the
key goals of this session thank you
thank you Excellency now let me invite
Cameroon
thank you president
Cameron is deeply concerned by the
current crisis situation in Sudan my
country is distressed by the Unspeakable
suffering of the people of Sudan as a
result of this renewed tension my
country calls for an immediate ceasefire
and a peaceful resolution of the crisis
we call on the belligerence to create
conditions for humanitarian assistance
to be properly deployed in the country
in order to help those who are suffering
and in distress Cameron also welcomes
the willingness of the Sudanese
authorities in power to
engage in dialogue and cooperation with
the UN Human Rights mechanisms
we encourage them to persevere in this
way in order to definitively restore
peace and coexistence in the interests
of Sudan's development furthermore my
country commands all initiatives aimed
at bringing peace to Sudan particularly
within the United Nations and Regional
initiatives led by igad Under the
auspices of the African Union the Arab
League and many others in this regard
Cameroon welcomes the action of the
office of the United Nations High
Commissioner for human rights its
interest and its strong involvement
aimed at protecting people and
preventing human rights violations
however my country believes that in its
human rights promotion Dimension the
ohchr should Place emphasis on
strengthening the rule of law and
promoting democracy because the
Resurgence of Crisis reflects a
democratic deficit finally my country
believes that the resolution that this
special sanction session must sanction
must send a message that promotes peace
and reduces hatred in Sudan it must
therefore be balanced and consensual and
take into account the expectations and
hopes of the population which is the
main target of all the human rights
violations going on thank you
Morocco
Socrates
thank you Mr President at the outset we
commend the efforts by the brotherly
Republic of Sudan and dealing in a
serious and fruitful interaction with
the ohchr Human Rights Council and
special procedures we also support this
our solidarity and absolute terms with
the Sudanese people and whilst we regret
the tragic situation in this brotherly
country
we also support the initiatives and step
by the Arab League including sending
humanitarians as assistants we also
welcome the efforts undertaken by other
countries and other International
organizations to bring parties closer
together and to pave the way and provide
an environment conducive to a
constructive dialogue
we hope that this we we will be able to
preserve the territorial integrity and
National sovereignty of Sudan to
preserve the wealth of its people by
returning to the voice of wisdom and the
peace process to find a solution to the
crisis in Sudan and to pave the way for
a new era which fulfills the aspirations
and hopes of the Sudanese people and
contributes to preserving security and
stability in this country at the same
time we insist on all parties to
immediately seize all form of military
clashes finally Mr President we would
like to thank all parties that
contributed and worked on providing safe
corridors
be it by air by C or by land in order to
secure the evacuation of innocent
civilians and diplomatic teams back to
their countries or to Safe areas outside
the conflict Zone thank you Mr President
thank you and let me join Belgium
we should president
president Belgium aligns itself with a
statement by the European Union
it is true that the Sudanese people has
for several weeks now been suffering the
heavy consequences of this conflict yet
their fundamental rights have been
flouted for much longer in 2019 a
movement one million people strong was
brave enough to rise up and demand
better living conditions and respect for
their civilian civil and political
rights sadly this transition has not yet
been completed on the contrary the
conflicts that have been raging on the
territory of Sudan since the 15th of
April have killed and wounded hundreds
of civilians and forced thousands of
people to be displaced within and
without Sudan
in addition to the security risks there
is a lacked of access to water and we
urge
an end to the conflict and we call Four
necessary conditions to be established
for return to dialogue and disability
and transition in accordance with the
will of the Sudanese people
we condemn
the Air Raids and generalized plundering
the longer the e-combats go on the
higher the risks of the situation
turning into a civil war with serious
Regional repercussions we are therefore
glad that the security Council and
Regional actors stood United in their
opposition to the conflict we support
all mediation initiatives that are
regionally anchored that however does
not exclude the urgent need for this
Council to respond to the Grave human
rights situation in Sudan
the lack of respect for human rights
will contribute to further exacerbating
the situation and will
make a sustainable solution ever harder
to achieve finally we welcome Sudan's
cooperation with the human rights office
both in cartoon and elsewhere
we believe that in light of the current
crisis it is only logical to strengthen
the support for the independent expert
on human rights so as to prevent fresh
violations of human rights we call on
all members of the council to support
the Sudanese people to maintain the
unity of the International Community and
to approve this resolution by consensus
thank you
civil the United States of America you
have the floor
thank you Mr President and I thank the
High Commissioner for his sobering
remarks they are a stark reminder of the
terrible human toll this latest conflict
has had on the people of Sudan hundreds
of civilians are dead and thousands
wounded countless more have been
suffering for weeks unable to leave
their homes for food water fuel medicine
treatment or to check on loved ones they
live in constant fear fear of the next
bomb dropped the next bullet fired the
next knock at the door to the people of
Sudan I say we stand with you and for
you we will not give up on you nor will
we turn away we cannot let the people of
Sudan lose hope it was this hope that
inspired Us in 2019 when the people Rose
to reclaim the destiny of Sudan after
Decades of misrule the people of Sudan
deserve better it is our responsibility
to listen to amplify their voices and to
push for peace at the same time we must
demand full respect for an National
human rights law in international
humanitarian law and that parties to the
conflict respect and protect civilians
including humanitarian Personnel we
certainly should all agree that any
attack or threat against humanitarian
and health workers is unacceptable I am
horrified and deeply concerned by
reports of targeting of hospitals and
health care providers forced recruitment
of children and gender-based violence
including conflict-related sexual
violence
we acknowledge those who say the world
should wait longer to address the human
rights and humanitarian aspects of this
tragedy however the U.S is of the clear
view the negotiations to establish a
ceasefire and get desperately needed
humanitarian assistance flowing to the
people of Sudan can and must occur at
the same time that our Council fulfills
its role and mandate in addressing the
dire human rights situation
in fact
this is the moment to send a clear
message to the parties that of the
conflict that the world is watching and
expects them to deliver for the people
of Sudan
parties to the conflict need to ensure
safe humanitarian access and the
protection of civilians and here at the
HRC we have a duty to help make that
more likely I would like to ask the
panel what can be done to strengthen
protection of civilians to include
members of all vulnerable groups I thank
you
thank you
La France
thank you very much president president
France aligns itself with the statement
by the European Union and we thank the
High Commissioner and the president of
the Coordinating Committee for the
clear-sighted presentations of the
situation and their calls for Urgent
action we would like to express our deep
concern at the about the conflict in
Sudan and we are concerned by the
increasing number of Civilian victims we
condemn the indiscriminate attacks and
violations against civilians and
humanitarian personnel and U.N staff
members the deliberate targeting of
Civilian infrastructure researchers
hospitals is unacceptable this situation
creates great displacement of
populations within Sudan and towards
neighboring countries and thousands of
civilians see their rights to
fundamental
Services violated and trampled access to
humanitarian Aid must be immediate and
unhindered we call on the Sudanese
forces to not take part in the fighting
we commend the efforts by the United
Nations the African Union and several
countries in the region including South
Sudan and Saudi Arabia as well as I get
the Arab League and the United States
efforts all aimed at achieving a
ceasefire and an enter the hostilities
only dialogue can ensure respect for a
permanent ceasefire and inclusive
political negotiation so as to find a
way out of the crisis president the
holding of this extraordinary session is
a clear signal from the International
Community respect for human rights and
fundamental freedoms and the protection
of civilians the return towards lasting
peace all go hand in hand in this
context we call for the protection of
journalists and human rights Defenders
to be respected
the peace building must rest on an
impartial and transparent judicial
process and the perpetrators of abuses
must be held to account this is
essential to avoid a repetition of
cycles of violence and to respond to the
needs of Justice of the victims that is
why we co-sponsor this resolution which
seeks to strengthen the documentation of
the abuses that are being committed and
we also call for the 2019 processes to
be pursued so as to re-establish
democracy France will provide
exceptional humanitarian assistance for
this crisis and
at the request of support from
neighboring countries which and we
commend this are welcoming civilians
fleeing the conflict thank you very much
now let me invite Malaysia
Mr President Melissa is following
closely the situation in Sudan we remain
deeply concerned over the continued
fighting in Sudan and strongly condemned
the hostilities which have caused
destruction of properties and loss of
innocent lives thus far the conflict has
resulted in hundreds of Civilian
casualties and tens of thousands more
have been displaced we are concerned
that a prolonged conflict will only lead
to further suffering for the Sudanese
people and they say stop the view that
the immediate priority for the situation
in Sudan is to anti-violence and
instability in the country their
Pharmacy believes that inclusive
dialogue and negotiations are the only
means to restore peace and stability in
Sudan we urge both parties to engage in
meaningful dialogue while safeguarding
the interests of the Sudanese people to
ensure ceasefire and to work towards a
peaceful resolution Mr commands Saudi
Arabia's efforts in facilitating peace
talks to reach immediate and Lasting
ceasefire in Sudan in this regard we
welcome the ongoing pre-negotiation
talks between the representatives of the
Sudanese armed forces and the rapid
support forces May ideated by Saudi
Arabia and the United States in Jeddah
in this regardless systems ready to
support Regional and international
mediation efforts to return Sudan to the
path of Peace Mr President Melissa is
deeply concerned with the dire
humanitarian conditions in Sudan
including food shortages as well as
limited access to health care
Transportation Communications and other
basic necessities therefore we underline
the need for establishment of
humanitarian corridors and unimpeded
access to humanitarian assistance into
and throughout Sudan we urge all parties
to Grant access to humanitarian Aid and
medical supplies and fully comply with
their obligations on the international
humanitarian law and international human
rights law as the situation remains
volatile we urge all parties in Sudan to
prioritize the Safety and Security of
civilians including the vulnerable
groups we also call on all parties to
allow a safe evacuation process for
foreign citizens Mercy would like to
take this opportunity to thank all
parties involved in the safe evacuation
of 33 family since n27 other citizens
especially Saudi Arabia the UAE and
Pakistan finally military means in
solidarity with the people of Sudan and
will continue to support efforts towards
finding a peaceful and amicable solution
to the ongoing conflict I thank you
thank you Czech Republic
thank you Mr President
the Czech Republic lines itself with the
EU statement the Czech Republic is
deeply concerned by the recent outbreak
of violence in Sudan the human situation
in the country is catastrophic we don't
know yet how many persons have been
killed and wounded during the ongoing
conflict
the numbers will be high we are worried
that it will be many more than the
reported hundreds of victims we are
concerned that the current situation
might evolve into a long-term conflict
affecting the whole country
we call on the Sudanese armed forces and
the rapid support forces to immediately
stop the fighting and respect the
ceasefire the situation in Sudan cannot
be solved by by an armed conflict excess
of humanitarian Aid must be facilitated
civilians must be protected it is
unacceptable to conduct attacks on
schools and Healthcare facilities in the
armed conflict
the situation is showing us the
fragility of states in democratic
transition just a few years ago we
expressed our support to the efforts of
the transitional government to improve
the human rights situation in Sudan and
to lead Sudan to democratic elections
it is unfortunate that the positive
developments in the country were stopped
by the
2021 Coupe and only two years later we
are witnessing these these hostilities
for these reasons the Czech Republic has
supported the submitted resolution and
we hope it will be adopted by consensus
I thank you
thank you and now let me invite
Montenegro
Mr President Montenegro shares serious
concerns about the great human rights
situation in Sudan exacerbated by the
outbreak of the conflict between the
Sudanese and forces and the rapid
support forces force on April 15. a
significant escalation of violence has
already led to the death of hundreds of
civilians and injuries 2000s including
children
then going fighting is also plagued by
The increased levels of sexual and
gender-based violence Mass displacement
and destruction of property in civilian
infrastructure the outbreak of
hostilities has further increased food
insecurity and threatenic access to
vital life facilities including
education and Healthcare Services water
and sanitation appears deteriorated
daughter-didai situation of millions
people approximately a third population
in the need of humanitarian assistance
overall heightened violence in Sudan
threatened the Safety and Security of
its people as well as the unique
instability of the country any further
escalation of the conflict could be
devastating for the country and efforts
to restore the civilian-led transition
towards democracy as the only patch to
Freedom peace and justice for all
Sudanese this reversing developments
also risks Regional destabilization we
strongly condemn ongoing fighting and
all relating reported violence and
abuses of Human Rights and violations of
international humanitarian law by all
parties to the conflict across the
country we joined a common appeal to all
parties for immediate Association of
hostilities without preconditions and
full respect for the ceasefire efforts
refer the call on All actors to allow
and facilitate Swift and unpided
humanitarian access to and evacuation of
civilians as well as to protect them and
assure the safety of humanitarian
International and diplomatic Personnel
Montenegro extended school support to
all ongoing efforts aimed at backing
dialogue and mediation towards returning
to the path of democracy for all this
reason Montenegro supported the core
groups request for convening the special
session on the human rights impact of
the ongoing conflict in Sudan we thank
the core group for its constructive
engagement during the consultation on
the table resolution on this matter and
call for its adoption Montenegro
reiterates its touch support and
solidarity with the Sudanese people and
shares their hopes and aspiration for
achieving lasting peace stability
Justice and democracy I thank you
thank you and now let me in mind the
delegation of China
follows closely the least developments
in Sudan
China calls on both parties to the
conflict to put the interests of the
country and the people first to achieve
a ceasefire as soon as possible so as to
create conducive conditions for
humanitarian assistance and to avoid
further escalation
China family supports Sudan's
sovereignty Independence and territorial
Integrity we trust that Sudan has the
wisdom and ability to handle its
National Affairs in Internal Affairs and
put an end to the conflict as soon as
possible and bring Sudan back to the
right track of Peace stability and
National development
we appreciate
The crucial role played by the Arab
League and the African Union
as well as the countries in the region
in dealing with the situation in Sudan
we note that the parties to the conflict
have started the negotiation process in
Saudi Arabia
the International Community should
earnestly respect these Sudan's
sovereignty and the ownership of his
Affairs support Sudan in exploring
institutional Arrangements that suits
its National conditions and create a
favorable external environment for
dialogue to solve the problem
in this context
the discussions and actions by the
council concerning the situation in
Sudan should help to put out the fire
and cool down the temperature so to
speak and not the opposite
China has always advocated that all
parties should solve their differences
in the field of Human Rights through
constructive dialogue and cooperation
therefore we are not in favor of holding
this special session still less
a dancer still has any uh taking of
action at the time when there is still
serious differences
which would only have long-term negative
impact on the work of the council thank
you Mr President
I thank you and what means Pakistan
you're the floor
thank you Mr President
we are deeply concerned over the
evolving situation in Sudan especially
its humanitarian and security dimensions
we are saddened over the loss of lives
our thoughts and solidarity are with the
brotherly people of Sudan affected by
the ongoing conflict
we reaffirm support for the sovereignty
and territorial Integrity of Sudan and
we fully support all mediation efforts
including by the African Union League of
Arab states the quartet and egad
we hope the recent meeting in Jeddah
facilitated by Saudi Arabia lays the
foundation for a durable peace
Mr President holding of a special
session of the council in our view does
not stand up to the broad markers
identified in the IB package
we raise this point in terms of
principles of objectivity dialogue and
cooperation
this session is also in contradiction to
working culture envisaged in HRC
resolution 5-1 such as exercising
restraint in proliferation of mandates
and avoiding unnecessary duplication of
work
in our view the U.N security Council is
already seized of the peace and security
dimension of the situation it has issued
a prsd and despite it being vested with
the Mandate and tools it has exercised
Prudence by deferring consideration of
the situation till next month
at this stage mediation efforts must be
given Primacy to secure ceasefire and
facilitate humanitarian assistance
we share concerns over the human rights
impacts of the conflict in Sudan these
impacts can however best be mitigated
when the ongoing conflict is managed
first
Sudan has demonstrated consistent
cooperation and engagement with the
council ohchr and human rights experts
including the existing mechanism
mounting another resolution with Noble
but unrealistic proposals is deemed
unhelpful
after all many of the asks are hard to
be achieved given the security situation
on the ground and the inherent
limitations of this Council
in any case the human rights expert on
Sudan is said to present his report
followed by an interactive dialogue in a
few weeks
the call for today's special session and
its outcomes which lack the consent of
country concern on a matter which
sequentially Falls within the Mandate of
U.N security Council risks further
exacerbating the situation in Sudan
we call for introspection and to work
with the country concerned to promote
the share cause of a peaceful Sudan
where human rights are fully respected
by all I think and now let me invite
Chile
thank you president
Chile would like to express its grave
concern in light of the dramatic
deterioration of the human rights
situation in Sudan over the last month
since the beginning of the armed
conflict between the rapid support first
forces and the Sudanese Armed Forces on
the 15th of April we call on all parties
involved to step up their efforts to
achieve a ceasefire to protect the
civilian population enable access for
humanitarian Aid and respect the rules
of international law international
humanitarian law and international human
rights law we would like to make a
special call for the serious situation
of women children and the space persons
to be taken into account especially in
light of reports of situations that are
posing a threat to their lives and
physical Integrity as well as the lack
of basic services and cases of sexual
and gender-based violence such
circumstances warrant a robust response
from the International Community to
ensure respect for and protection of
human rights in Sudan
Chile would therefore like to express
its support for Sudan in its efforts to
achieve a peaceful settlement to the
conflict which will allow for lasting
peace and the well-being of its
population therefore we would like to
highlight the constructive role of
international organizations in this
process in particular the office of the
High Commissioner for human rights and
the special procedures under this
Council
which can of course work along with
other un agencies and Regional
mechanisms such as the African Union and
the Arab League thank you very much
thank you and the next speaker is Mexico
thank you president
Mexico would like to express its concern
about the deterioration of the
humanitarian and human rights situation
in the Republic of Sudan the information
about the situation on the ground shows
that there is an urgent need for there
to be an in-depth discussion within this
Council which is why my country
supported the convening of this special
session
Mexico recognizes the efforts made by
national Regional and international
actors in order to put in place a
ceasefire and an end to the conflict
however in light of the current
situation my country would like to call
on all parties to the conflict to
immediately cease hostilities and to
find a negotiated solution and to resume
the process of transition which will
allow for the full implementation of
international human rights obligations
and obligations under International
humanitarian law
sustainable peace as well as
safeguarding human rights in particular
for vulnerable groups must be the
priority in light of the information
received about the human rights
situation Republic of Sudan we have
carefully analyzed the resolution which
is being presented today
we are glad that a progressive approach
of existing mechanisms has been adopted
this is something that my country has
repeatedly called for within this
Council that said my country would like
to highlight that the emergency of the
humanitarian situation or human rights
situation in a given country or region
should not mean this Council must adopt
resolutions that leave aside the
establishment of a constructive dialogue
of the state concerned including
elements such as its concerns or
priorities failing to do so not only
reduces the effectiveness of proposed
mechanisms but also jettison's the
spirit of cooperation and respect which
should Prevail as The Guiding thread in
this council's actions to ensure that
states can fulfill their human rights
obligations and obligations under
International humanitarian and human
rights law thank you
thank you and the next speaker on my
list is India
thank you Mr President India has long
standing friendly relations with Sudan
and its people
over the years India has emerged as a
development partner of Sudan and has
assisted Sudan in implementing several
projects through grants and concessional
lines of credit doing capacity building
and providing humanitarian assistance we
are closely monitoring the complex and
evolving security situation in Sudan
we are concerned over the loss of
Civilian lives injuries and destruction
the conflict has also negatively
affected the enjoyment of Human Rights
by people of Sudan
we have been coordinating closely with
various partners for the safe movement
of those Indians who were impacted by
the conflict and wanted to be evacuated
and we have been able to safely evacuate
about 4000 Indian Nationals as well as
Nationals of other countries from Sudan
in coordination with our partners
India has been consistently underscoring
the importance of mutual trust
engagement dialogue and Reconciliation
to resolve the conflict in Sudan we have
urged all sides to exercise restraint
and work together to build trust and
confidence which would pave the way for
dialogue and transition towards a
civilian-led government
peace and stability in Sudan is of
utmost importance for India for the
entire African continent and for the
world Mr President India hopes to see
Sudan emerge as a prosperous peaceful
and stable country
and towards that objective we will
continue to support Sudan and its people
we remain confident that the people of
Sudan will overcome the current
challenges and make progress towards
securing a stable and prosperous future
I thank you Mr President
I thank you
and now let me in mind Senegal
thank you president
Senegal
expresses full solidarity with Sudan and
its people
my delegation remains deeply concerned
by the fresh outbreak of violence in
some regions of the country
leading to mass population displacement
destruction of property and
infrastructure and loss of human life
this situation imperils the extensive
efforts made towards peace and suit
stability in Sudan and requires special
attention from the International
Community
in this regard
Senegal welcomes
Regional mediation initiatives taken by
igad supported by the African Union
and a group of States including Saudi
Arabia the UAE the United Kingdom and
the United States
we also call on the parties involved in
the conflict to be fully committed to
dialogue
and an immediate cessation of
hostilities as well as complete respect
for human rights and civilian protection
including protection of the most
vulnerable
my country further calls on the council
and the International Community to
provide Sudan with the necessary
assistance to respond to Urgent
humanitarian needs of conflict affected
populations and to restore security and
stability throughout the territory
in conclusion
while commending Sudan's ongoing
collaboration with the council's
mechanisms
Senegal reaffirms its commitment to a
peaceful and Lasting settlement to this
conflict within the framework of
constructive dialogue with the country
concerned I thank you Vietnam
Mr President Vietnam shares the
international communities concerns about
the conflict situation in Sudan and
urji's own parties to cease fire observe
International humanitarian law ensure
access to humanitarian act and Safeguard
civilians and essential infrastructure
writer to human life
the immediate priority is finding a
solution to end the conflict
the efforts of the International
Community should contribute to this goal
would lead the most appropriate security
peace and humanitarian Frameworks
consistent with international law and
the charter of the UN United Nations
Vietnam believes that conflicts
resolution requires the participation of
Sudanese stakeholders and the promotion
of the role of the United Nation and
Regional organization an armed conflict
related to International Peace and
security should be discussed in an
appropriate mechanism
we reiterate our consistent position
that Vietnam does not support country's
specific resolutions that like the
consent of the concerned country and
opposes the politicization of Human
Rights is used as a tool to interfere in
the internet in Internal Affairs of
country which is inconsistent with
international law and the principles set
forth in the U.N Charter Vietnam
strongly believes that the optimal way
to promote and protect human rights is
through the new dialogue and cooperation
I thank you Mr President
thank you and we continue with Costa
Rica
Gracia
deterioration of the situation of human
rights in Sudan my country true to and
consistent with its commitments as a
member of this Council would like to
reiterate its principled position which
is that human rights are Universal
indivisible and interdependent and that
no country region or situation is above
the scrutiny of the Human Rights Council
therefore we have since the beginning
supported the convening of this special
session which is in keeping with the
Mandate of this un specialized body the
conflict in Sudan has resulted in
multiple challenges for human rights
including violations to the right
violations of the right to life and
freedom and safety of persons as well as
the right to education access to water
and sanitation to healthcare and basic
needs and the right to labor amongst
others the hostilities have exacerbated
the human rights crisis of the
internally displaced persons and
refugees affecting also neighboring
countries
women and children are particularly
vulnerable to sexual and gender-based
violence during armed conflicts in this
case there have been reports of rape and
children recruited by the armed forces
and users child soldiers
in light of the gravity of the situation
on the ground the Human Rights Council
has the unavoidable responsibility of
responding to these multiple challenges
amongst other things ensuring
appropriate accountability for human
rights violations committed during the
conflict by all parties
impunity perpetuates the cycle of
violence and makes it more difficult for
victims to obtain Justice and reparation
and it prevents this is the people and
of Sudan from moving towards
reconciliation and Lasting peace Costa
Rica calls on all parties to immediately
cease all hostilities to respect the
international human rights obligations
and international humanitarian law and
to cooperate with this council with the
ICC the efforts of the International
Community Regional organizations and
Civil Society in order to ensure
accountability human rights and the rule
of law thank you
thank you and we continue with
Luxembourg
president thank
you convening of this special session we
express our full solidarity with the
people of Sudan who have been paying a
heavy price since the 15th of April when
clashes broke out between the Armed
Forces of general al-buhan and the rsf
led by General de gallo
the disregard of the warning sides for
the security of civilians and for IHL is
flagrant this disregard is the direct
consequence of many years of impunity as
noted by the High Commissioner the
current fighting is a result of a
personal tussle for power between the
two generals who dismiss the Democratic
legitimate Democratic aspirations of the
population this Council met for a
special session in November 2021 to
address the military coup d'etat carried
out by these same two men the previous
month at the time they had the shared
goal of putting an end to the democratic
transition that had followed a peaceful
and popular revolution in Sudan the
humanitarian situation in the country is
devastating with hundreds of thousands
of displaced and hundreds of civilians
killed my delegation joins others in
demanding that the parties of the
conflict fully respect their obligations
and to international human rights law
and international humanitarian law
especially when it comes to protection
of civilians they must above all refrain
from using explosive weapons in densely
populated areas the parties to the
conflict must allow for unfettered
Access of humanitarian Aid we also call
for protection of Human Rights Defenders
including women right human rights
Defenders specifically who have been
threatened for their cause for peace and
accountability the time has come to
place the interests of the Sudanese
people at the Forefront and for an
underlayed return to the democratic
transition while
highlighting violations and abuses of
Human Rights while putting an end to the
cultural impunity that has led to the
current conflict this is why Luxembourg
supports the resolution tabled before us
which seeks to bolster the Mandate of
the expert and calls on the ohchr to
keep the council informed of the
situation in Sudan
we call on all council members to do
likewise I thank you see now let me
invite South Africa
thank you Mr President
we thank the High Commissioner for his
candidates yet grave statement on the
human rights situation in Sudan
and the outset allow me to express my
delegation solidarity with the people of
Sudan who have been subjected to
unimaginable suffering since the
outbreak of hostilities on 15 April 2023
the injuries had deprivation suffered in
the deaths of innocent civilians
including children together with Untold
damages have been inflicted on the
civilian infrastructure is of grave
concern
indeed the significant escalation in the
conflict is serving to unleash a
humanitarian catastrophe in a country
which was already in a precarious
humanitarian situation
this has in turn created a new wave of
humanitarian challenges which are
threatening to engulf the whole region
it is for this reason that South Africa
joins those voices today which are
urging the parties to the conflict to
reach agreement on an unconditional and
Lasting ceasefire in order to address
the dire humanitarian situation in the
country
this ceasefire is an absolute and
overriding priority as it is fundamental
to the establishment of humanitarian
corridors necessary for unhindered
humanitarian access and the evacuation
of injured civilians these corridors are
also essential to addressing the
rehabilitation of critical in
infrastructure including water
electricity and in ensuring civilians
are able to have access to these
services
South Africa therefore welcomes the
talks that are currently taking place in
Jeddah for this purpose together with
the ongoing Regional efforts being
deployed by igart Under the auspices of
the AU
these efforts will no doubt go a long
way in securing the resumption of the
political process through dialogue and
negotiations towards the establishment
of an inclusive Democratic transitional
civilian-led government which the people
of Sudan have long yearned for these
Regional efforts also underscore the
importance of the application of the
principle of complementarity and
subsidiarity in ensuring that those who
are directly affected by the conflict
take the lead in determining its
resolution
in this regard it is important that the
initiative that we undertake at the
council today safe to bolster the
regional efforts to restore
peace in Sudan to resolve the conflict
as well as to estab to stabilize the
situation and silence the guns in the
country even at this late hour we urge
this Council to speak with one voice
Kyrgyzstan
is still right there okay thank you Mr
chairman Kyrgyzstan Hales the noble
efforts of our brothers from the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia
and those of the United States to
restore peace and respect to human lives
and human rights in Sudan
according to the Reliable Reports the
chances are high that today a ceasefire
might be reached in Jeddah
that would allow the immediate delivery
of emergency humanitarian assistance
which we believe is the most important
immediate task
we believe that today's deliberations
and the fact of the convening this
session did already greatly contribute
to the cause of reaching a ceasefire
which is crucial and indispensable
for restoring respect to the human
rights in Sudan thank you
thank you now let me invite Qatar
thank you Mr chair we would like to
align ourselves with the statements of
the groups to which we belong our
country reiterates its determination to
promote and protect human rights in
Sudan and our determined position
regarding the sovereignty and territory
Integrity of Sudan we reiterate our
solidarity with the Sudanese people and
these are circumstances that require
joining National and Regional and
international efforts in order to
restore peace and stability in this
brotherly country my country is
following up with concern the
developments in Sudan and recall about
upon all parties to resort to the voice
of reason to restraint to give priority
to public interest and to do everything
possible to
save the civilians from the impact of
this conflict we hope that this crisis
will be sold through dialogue and
peaceful settlement we commend all
International and Regional efforts
deployed currently in order to end this
crisis namely the negotiations and talks
taking place in the city of Jeddah under
the U.S Saudi initiative aiming at
reaching a lasting ceasefire and
allowing humanitarian assistance access
to civilians we hope the success of
these talks will lead to a real peaceful
and Lasting settlement of this crisis
We call we avoid we invite all parties
to resort to the aspirations of the
Sudanese people their aspirations to
peace stability and prosperity we invite
the ohthr and the High Commissioner to
provide the technical assistance to help
the Sudanese government to fulfill its
duties in terms of protecting and
promoting human rights recall upon the
International Community to provide the
Urgent humanitarian assistance and to
support the Sudanese people under these
difficult circumstances thank you Mr
President thank you and now let me
invite Eritrea
president
from the outside territory I believe is
bringing to an immediate and the present
conflict in Sudan is an urgent necessity
in essence the present conflict could be
seen in relation to the undesirable
Trend followed by the political process
of nation building introduced with the
policization of Islam after the Advent
of the nif in power three decades ago
the popular movement of 2019 supported
by the Army was intended to rectify and
address distortions created by nif
missile
to the transitional phase to a new
political dispensation should continue
to the Solomon and decisive task of the
people of Sudan who is able to resolve
difficulties of higher magnitude
regionally first by a god aimed at
complementing Homegrown Solutions are
also welcome
while we acknowledge then the need to
respect for human rights
the continued meddling by some foreign
countries and entities in the internal
affairs of Sudan in the pretext of Human
Rights
that's an initiative by the HRC should
take the above Sun's inconsideration and
avoid policization of Human Rights
furthermore the focus is made on
addressing the root cause and solutions
it should be important to give any
follow-up on the protection of human
rights in the prevailing crisis through
the existing established mechanism of
human rescue thank you
thank you and the last member speaking
is Cote d'Ivoire on behalf of African
States
microphone please and start again
Next Room
my apologies president I have the honor
of delivering this statement on behalf
of the Africa group the Africa group is
following the crisis in Sudan and we
stand in solidarity of the Sudanese
people in these difficult times we are
convinced that this poses a threat to
peace and human development as a whole
in the region and we support the
convening of the special session and we
regret though that it did not receive
the necessary attention from other
states we
support the idea of African solutions
for African problems therefore we
commend the mediation efforts of igad
under the auspices of the African Union
we commend all the additional efforts
that are made
through deployments by Regional
stakeholders and the council should
step up its peaceful initiatives
alongside with iget we believe that
peace is the utmost priority so a
ceasefire is of the essence so as to
ensure the provision of humanitarian
assistance which people so desperately
need in the conflict affected areas
we call for political conciliation we
call for the negotiations under the
auspices of Saudi Arabia and the United
States to continue so as to uphold a
ceasefire we would like to underscore
our constant support for the sovereignty
and Independence of Sudan as well as the
importance of dialogue and cooperation
in order to protect and promote human
rights
and we call for all necessary support to
be given to Sudan including political
economic Technical and development
assistance so as to help the country
overcome the difficulties of a
transition process we call on all
parties in Sudan to continue a dialogue
so as you find a consensus-based
solution to the political impasse in
Sudan and to lead the country towards a
peaceful transition
towards democracy we welcome the
corporation from the Sudanese government
with the expert of the United Nations on
Sudan and we call for this Corporation
to continue we call for the officer
commissioner to continue its support to
the Sudanese
country
and to take into accounts the needs and
demands of the country concerned thank
you we will now continue with the list
of speakers for observers days of the
council the speaking time will be one
minute and 30 seconds and the first
service date on my list is Liechtenstein
Liechtenstein where the floor
thank you Mr President
Stein has been among the delegations
that have supported the request for the
special session since we are concerned
about the outbreak of hostilities on 15
April 2023 and its subsequent escalation
of violence in particular we are
concerned about reports of serious
violations of international humanitarian
law including the numerous reports of
conflict-related sexual and gender-based
violence attacks against humanitarian
personnel and civilians and looting and
destruction of Civilian or humanitarian
property
the outbreak of hostility has led to a
significant rise of people in need of
humanitarian assistance and hundreds of
thousands of people fleeing the violence
putting additional strain on the region
it has also severely impacted the
enjoyment of Human Rights including the
right to life to food and to health we
urge the parties to the conflict to lay
down their weapons and to immediately
return the country to its civilian-led
government it is our joint obligation to
ensure accountability for violations of
international humanitarian and human
rights law and to support the Sudanese
people in their plight for sustainable
peace democracy and the full enjoyment
of their human rights I thank you Mr
President
thank you and that meanwhite Australia
you Mr President Australia welcomes a
special session on Sudan at this vital
time for the Sudanese people Australia
condemns the ongoing violence between
the Sudanese armed forces and the rapid
support forces which has resulted in the
needless deaths of hundreds and injury
to many thousands reports of widespread
human rights abuses and violations
including sexual and gender-based
violence are deeply troubling
as our attacks on diplomats humanitarian
officials and the premises of
international organizations we urge all
parties to the conflict to uphold
International humanitarian law and
protect civilians Sudan is heading for a
humanitarian catastrophe all parties
must ensure urgent humanitarian support
reaches those in need and afford all
necessary protections to health and
humanitarian workers as they seek to
alleviate the widespread suffering we
commend the efforts of the International
Community in seeking to negotiate a
permanent truce including recent talks
between the parties in Jeddah Australia
urges all parties to the conflict to
permanently cease hostilities and to
engage in meaningful negotiations a
negotiated solution including a pathway
to civilian rule is the only way forward
for the people of Sudan thank you
thank you I'm passing the floor to Japan
thank you Miss Japanese greatly
concerned about the situation in Sudan
that undermined their transition to
civilian through based on this
constitutional declaration foreign
is also deeply concerned about the
worsening humanitarian situation and the
cause for All actors to stop the
violence immediately
Japan tends to provoke actively address
the issue of Sudan including through the
engagement of facilitated by its
Ambassador special Envoy for the Forum
of Africa furthermore as prime minister
kishida stated during his visit to
Africa last week in order to respond to
the fostering segmentarian situation in
Sudan and its neighboring countries
Japan stands ready to provide the
emergency humanitarian system to Refugee
in neighboring countries and to inter
internally displaced persons in
cooperation with the international
organizations Japan strongly hopes that
the long-term stability will be achieved
in Sudan and the human rights will be
protected Japan together with the G7 and
other like-minded countries intends to
support Sudanese are forced to toward
the restoration of the transition to
civilian rule in colors compression with
the region countries and other
stakeholders I thank you
thank you Republic of Korea
thank you
the Republic of Korea is deeply
concerned of the ongoing armed conflict
between the Sudanese and forces and the
rapid support forces
which is caused the devastating impact
on the shimonite and humanitarian
situation in Sudan
since the outbreak of the hostilities we
have witnessed happy fighting and
airstrikes in populated areas resulting
in more than 500 deaths and the fourth
in tens of thousands fully it is also
traveling that a large number of
civilians have been caught in the cruise
fire with limited access to food water
and electricity
record on all parties to immediately
exist all hostilities and allow safe
passage for civilians in compliance with
international human rights and
humanitarian law by delegation is also
traveled by the tragic communicating
situation in Sudan the Federal Security
condition and attacks against Aid
workers continue to hamper humanitarian
operations leaving millions of people
without life-saving assistance unhind
the humanitarian access and the safety
which monitoring workers must be fully
insured in order to avoid a further
deterioration of the crisis it is
crucial for all parties to silence the
guns and the returns to negotiation with
table
we need full support for the ongoing
mediation efforts the Republic career
informed is a steadfast commitment to
restoring peace in Sudan and its
Democratic tension I thank you
thank you Monaco you have the floor
thank you president
the principality of Monaco strongly
condemns the human rights violations
currently ongoing in Sudan
and we express a solidarity with the
Sudanese people
since the 15th of April 2023 the
security situation has been
deteriorating in a drastic way the
escalation of violence that we are
witnessing has already cost the lives of
hundreds of people over the last three
weeks intense fighting has displaced
several
hundreds of thousands of civilians it
has led to the destruction of key Public
Health infrastructure and is threatening
to worsen the already severe food
insecurity in the country in this regard
the principality of Monaco calls for a
return to conditions that allow for
immediate and unhindered access of
humanitarian Aid to the populations
affected by the conflict my delegation
also calls on all the parties involved
to put an end to the violence and to
seek a political and negotiated solution
so as to resume the democratic
transition that was underway in light of
how serious the situation is Monaco
supported the convening of this special
session and decided to co-sponsor the
resolution being put before the council
we believe it is vital to strengthen the
Mandate of the expert on human rights in
Sudan and for the council to be kept
regularly appraised of developments in
the country thank you
Bulgaria
Mr President Bulgaria alliance with the
youth statement and supports the
convening of this special session for
the following reasons the outbreak of
hostilities in the Sudan between the
Sudanese armed forces and the rapid
support forces and the escalation of
violence across the country have led to
the death of hundreds of civilians
thousands of injured Mass internal and
external displacement thus unfolding a
human rights crisis and a dramatic
deterioration of the humanitarian
situation Bulgaria condemns all reported
abuses and violations of human rights
and of international humanitarian law
committed by all parties to the conflict
and insists that further violations be
immediately stopped we appeal to All
actors in The Sudan to take effective
measures for the protection of civilians
foreign Nationals health and
humanitarian workers and of the staff of
the UN and other International
organizations and ensure safe and
unhindered the humanitarian assistance
and access to all those in need with a
focus on vulnerable groups such as idps
women children the elderly and the
disabled Bulgaria urges all parties to
the conflict in Sudan to immediately
cease hostilities and engage in Urgent
talks to resolve the current crisis we
call on all parties in the Sudan tourism
from the political process aimed at
appointing a transitional civilian
government and holding elections at a
later stage and strongly support all
Regional International efforts to that
end we believe that the promotion and
the protection of Human Rights the rule
of law and accountability for all
violations and crimes committed will be
a solid foundation for a lasting
solution to the current crisis I thank
you
thank you and I'm passing the floor to
the Holy See
thank you Mr President the Holy See has
been following with deep concern the
developments of the Grave situation of
conflict and violence that has been
unfolding in Sudan as the suffering of
the people and humanitarian needs
increase the Holy See wishes to assure
once again its spiritual closeness
prayers and solidarity with the Sudanese
people especially the displays and the
refugees
the Holy See is particularly concerned
with the grave humanitarian and human
rights implications of the conflict and
urges all parties to suspend armed
attacks and ensure access to basic and
essential services for the civilian
population wherever they are needed
which includes allowing the safe
delivery of humanitarian assistance in
this regard the Holy See hopes that the
truce may be extended and be fully
respected and that the negotiations
between the representatives of all
parties in the conflict may result in a
fruitful agreement for a ceasefire and
for peaceful and durable Solutions in
the interest of the Sudanese population
as well as to avoid the risk of the
violence spread to neighboring countries
undermining Regional peace and security
in conclusion the Holy See remains
confident that dialogue in a spirit of
fraternity may bring about a just and
Lasting peace this delegation wishes to
Echo the appeal and prayers of Pope
Francis so that arms might be laid down
and dialogue Prevail in order to return
together to the path of peace and
Harmony I thank you Mr President
thank you and now let me invite
Indonesia
thank you Mr President Mr President
today's special session would only be
beneficial if the aspiration of Sudan as
the country concerned were considered
leading up to this meeting we heard the
position of Sudan Indonesia Echoes their
concern and request for this Council to
prioritize supporting ceasefire and
humanitarian efforts ongoing violences
Must Be Stopped to protect civilian from
further catastrophes in this hour of
need Indonesia emphasizes the following
first we call for Relevant parties to
immediately end the violence declared an
immediate ceasefire and return to
dialogue in which I support the ongoing
effort by Regional and other
International actors we emphasize that
inclusive political dialogue is
essential toward a democratic transition
process second we urge the International
Community to strengthen coordination and
ensure adequate resources for
humanitarian responses the present
authorities continue to ensure and
invented and safe humans and Corridor to
deliver it and evacuate civilian
prioritizing women and children and
members of the diplomatic Mission third
we reiterate the importance of the
importance to deliver technical
assistance and response to the needs and
priorities the council should
continuously provide capacity building
in the field of human rights in support
of an inclusive National reconciliation
process and is extended to support the
people of Sudan in their Journey towards
peace and prosperity thank you Mr
chairman
I thank you Kingdom of the Netherlands
thank you Mr President
the kingdom of the Netherlands aligns
itself with the EU statement and we
thank the core group for taking the
initiative for this special session on
Sudan the Netherlands strongly supports
the decision to enhance the Mandate of
the high commissioner's designated
expert
the Netherlands is greatly concerned by
the use of Violence by both the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Armed
Forces against the civilians and
healthcare workers
an estimated 70 percent of the hospitals
in Khartoum are close because of the
targeted attacks and shortness of
supplies the Netherlands therefore
strongly condemns these violent
violations of international humanitarian
law preventing people from basic rights
such as access to food water and care
the ongoing abuses and violations need
to be documented and the evidence
collected preserved so that perpetrators
on both sides can be held accountable
for their crimes
who urge both the saf and the rsf to end
this conflict immediately and fully
abide by ceasefire efforts Mr High
Commissioners ladies and gentlemen
all efforts should be focused on ending
these humanitarian human rights and
international humanitarian law
violations and create safe corridors to
provide humanitarian Aid the Netherlands
is ready to support all efforts to
obtain the solution and reaffirms its
solidarity with the people of Sudan
thank you
thank you Brazil is the next
thank you Mr President Brazil is closely
following the human rights situations in
Sudan we are very concerned about the
unparalleled level of violence since the
outbreak of the clashes on April 15th
and its impacts on human rights
we commend the seven neighboring
countries of Sudan for keeping their
borders open and receiving displaced
persons
the attacks on civilians civilian
facilities including hospitals and
schools and the Looting of offices of
civil society and international
organizations as well as diplomatic
missions are unacceptable
we reiterate our call for full Respect
by all bodies to International
humanitarian law and the Vienna
Convention of 1961.
we read the rate or call for immediate
cessation of hostilities that could
allow unimpeded access to humanitarian
assistance
we support the efforts of the African
Union the intergovernmental Authority
for development the league of Arab
states the United Nations and its
Security Council
in seeking lasting political solutions
for the ongoing crisis recalling the 19
2019 constitutional declaration and the
framework agreement of 2022 we hope for
the achievement of a political
understanding leading to the return to a
civilian-led government with full
respect for human rights in Sudan thank
you thank you and I'm inviting Peru
thank you president Peru supports the
convening of this special session of the
Council on the
human rights impact in of the situation
in Sudan in light of the severe armed
conflict affecting the country
we deeply lament the tragic loss of
hundreds of lives including of children
and young people as well as reports of
sexual aggression against Sudanese women
Peru agrees with what was said by the
High Commissioner folkert regarding the
immediate ceasefire this is
of vital
significance and we urge the parties to
the conflict to immediately end
hostilities and to comply with
International humanitarian law we urge
the parties to the conflict to respect
human rights to protect the civilian
population and to enforce the right to
justice for everyone and ensure
accountability for violations
we call on International Community to
step up its efforts to support dialogue
in favor of a ceasefire so as to meet
the needs of the Sudanese people for a
peaceful and Democratic future in which
their human rights are respected thank
you
thank you Switzerland
definition of the Mandate of the expert
appointed by the ohchr for Sudan
we are seriously concerned by the
violent clashes taking place in Sudan
since the 15th of April we call on the
parties to the conflict to reach an
immediate ceasefire to enable
speedy and unhinded humanitarian access
and to allow for dialogue to be resumed
my country is alarmed by the disastrous
humanitarian consequences caused by the
conflict which has already cost the
lives of hundreds of civilians and
forced the displacement of tens of
thousands of people we condemn
violations of IHL and international
human and human rights law including
attacks on hospitals we urge the parties
to the conflict to take all measures
required to protect the civilian
population maintaining the internet
connection is also crucial to ensure
that persons affected can communicate
with their relatives and access reliable
information and
products of basic necessity and
information about safe evacuation routes
finally Switzerland affirms its support
for efforts
of mediation by the International
Community including by neighboring
states Partners in the region the UN the
African Union and igad we call on the
parties to the conflict to cooperate
fully with these stakeholders to put an
end to the hostilities and find a
lasting political solution thank you is
Uruguay
thank you president
Uruguay views with concern the ongoing
deterioration of the situation in the
Republic of Sudan
this is aggravated by the clashes
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Armed Forces which
is worsening a negative picture which
also affects respect for human rights we
condemn attacks against civilians and
civilian infrastructure and we are
horrified by the increasing death toll
and the number of wounded people and
people forced to flee a context of
violence and danger we are concerned by
difficulties for humanitarian assistance
as well as the continuous reports of
physical and sexual violence against
women and girls and boys
in light of this situation the council
must respond it must respond within its
remit to ensure that there are no new
victims
on this basis Uruguay co-sponsored the
convening of this special session
Ally we support the call from The High
Commissioner for an immediate cessation
of hostilities and for the prompt
launching of Investigations we urge all
of the parties involved to find a
settlement for this crisis through
peaceful means to ensure full respect
for human rights and international
humanitarian law finally we urge them to
cooperate with this Council and with the
office of the High Commissioner and with
the appointed expert thank you I give
the floor to Ecuador
thank you president
Ecuador is taking part in this special
session with great dismay in light of
the violence in Sudan and the Resurgence
of hostilities since the 15th of April
which have triggered an alarming
humanitarian crisis we deplore all
actions that are counter to Human Rights
and international humanitarian law
including attacks against humanitarian
workers and civilian infrastructure
especially hospitals and airports
we also lament the loss of hundreds of
lives including those of women and
children during the fighting between the
Sudanese armed forces and the rapid
support forces we also deplore the
increase in sexual and gender-based
violence
we urge for international human rights
law and international humanitarian or to
be respected we call for humanitarian
corridors to be established for the
evacuation of civilians and for the
safety of humanitarian staff to be
insured
also it is vital to address the critical
situation of internally displaced
persons in the Darfur and also of women
and girls fleeing violence Ecuador
Echoes the call for the parties of the
conflict to immediately cease
hostilities and to resume dialogue in
order to resolve the crisis in Sudan in
a way that is respectful of Human Rights
and Democratic principles finally we
believe it is vital to support Regional
and international efforts to return the
country to a path of transition towards
a constitutional order thank you thank
you and now let me invite Croatia
Mr President Croatia aligns itself with
the youth statement the gravity scale
and the complexity of current crisis in
Sudan is manifested in a high level of
Civilian casualties displacement
destruction migration and suffering of
the most vulnerable parts of the
population including women and children
Croatia strongly condemns the ongoing
military attacks motivated by the
struggle for power we call upon All
actors in Sudan to ensure protection of
civilians including against sexual and
gender-based violence we call upon all
parties to the conflict to immediately
stop the hostilities and refrain from
further violations and abuses of Human
Rights and to seize the violations on
International humanitarian law
we emphasize the important role of the
Civil Society whose peaceful struggle
and sacrifice for democracy should get
more prominence at the international
support Mr President it is imperative to
to ensure ceasefire humanitarian access
and corridors for the evacuation of
civilians we call upon Sudan to ensure
meaningful domestic accountability for
all violations and abuses Sudan is of
course is of crucial importance for the
stability and of the entire North East
Africa the lives of millions are at
stake the worst is yet to come it seems
and vegetables utmost to prevent it
thank you
thank you and the next speaker is
Boulevard and Republic of Venezuela
thank you president Venezuela is
concerned by the conflict in Sudan and
we deeply lament the loss of life and
the difficult humanitarian situation the
convening of this special session and
the resolution that is being put forward
by the co-sponsors does not have the
consent of the state concerned it
ignores Regional initiatives currently
underway in order to achieve a ceasefire
and Advance peace it would be prudent to
support the efforts of the Arab League
and the African Union in addressing this
situation with the consent of the
country concerned Venezuela believes it
is necessary to support these important
initiatives which are conducive to
effective protection and promotion of
Human Rights once again we call on our
peace-minded diplomacy we call for any
action that might lead to an escalation
to cease my country is a firm defender
of the principles and goals of the
charter and we call for dialogue between
the parties in order to preserve life
human rights and establish
stability in the country and the region
we reaffirm our firm commitment to the
Supreme values of Peace friendship and
solidarity between the world's Nations
and we will continue to Advocate a
peaceful settlement of disputes on the
basis of the universal principles of
respect for sovereignty and
non-interference in Internal Affairs of
states enshrined in the uncharter thank
you and the next speaker is Malta
thank you Mr President
modernize itself with the statement of
the European Union
Malta expresses deep concern regarding
the current human rights situation in
Sudan we deeply regret that much of the
fighting has been concentrated in
heavily populated parts of Khartoum and
residential areas elsewhere in the
country which has exposed civilians to
death and injury
we also regret the intense clashes in
several States in Darfur that resulted
in considerable fatalities injuries and
heavy infrastructural damage
we are also concerned with the ensuing
precarious humanitarian situation
experienced by those trapped and
displaced by the fighting who are unable
to access basic services medical care
food and water
we call on both parties to the conflict
to ensure respect for the obligation for
their obligations on the international
humanitarian and human rights law and
the protection of civilians and civilian
infrastructures such as schools and
hospitals
furthermore we are appalled by the
reports of sexual and gender-based
violence and call on both parties for
the conflict to take all necessary
measures to take preventive measures
Malta ages thorough and independent
investigations into reported violations
and for those responsible to be held
accountable
finally we call on all parties to
de-escalate tensions and to put shared
interest of the Sudanese people first I
thank you Mr President
thank you and we continue with Cyprus
thank you Mr President Cyprus aligns
itself with a statement by the European
Union since the outbreak of facilities
the human rights and the humanitarian
situation in Sudan has rapidly
deteriorated especially impacting women
and girls we urge all parties to the
conflict to mediate these hostilities
and to fully respect their obligations
under international law there is an
urgent need to provide immediate
humanitarian assistance to the people of
Sudan the deliberate denial and
obstruction of humanitarian access is a
blatant violation of international
humanitarian law Cyprus supports
Regional and international efforts to
implement a lasting and sustainable
ceasefire agreement and we welcome all
mediation efforts towards this end
furthermore the efforts by neighboring
states that have kept their borders open
and are assisting refugees must not go
unnoticed beyond the imperative
overlasting ceasefire National
reconciliation process and the formation
of an inclusive government promoting
accountability and Paving the way for
the democratic transition of done is an
integral part of the overall solution
during evacuation efforts from Sudan
undertaken recently Cyprus was a safe
transit app and we shall continue to
contribute whenever needed by the
International Community in humanitarian
evacuation efforts I thank you
thank you and I'm inviting Ethiopia
Mr President
Ethiopia aligns with itself with the
statement delivered by the
representative of Cote d'Ivoire on
behalf of the African group and would
like to make the following remarks
Ethiopia has a neighboring country is
Gravely concerned over the ongoing
fighting and appeals to those parties of
the conflict to stop the fighting and
Allah humanitarian relief and assistance
to the people that are in need Ethiopia
underscores that there can only be a
political solution to the crisis and
advocates for its resolution on the
basis of the principle of African
solutions to African problems
in this regard Ethiopia's recent peace
agreement to resolve the conflict in the
northern part of the country concept as
a useful example accordingly we stress
on the importance of giving priority to
existing Regional and Continental
mechanisms to resolve the crisis namely
the efforts of igad under those pieces
of the African Union
proliferation of initiatives and
mandates is counterproductive in this
connection we find this specialization
to be untimely
any new mechanism to be successful
should be owned by the sudanis
themselves and be based on the concept
of the concerned country on the basis of
the principle of complementarity we
emphasize on the respect of Sudan's
National sovereignty territory integrity
and political Independence finally we
wish to express our solidarity with the
brotherly people of Sudan at this
difficult time I thank you
thank you and the next speaker is
Ireland
thank you Mr President Ireland aligns
with the statement of the EU we are
deeply concerned by the devastating
consequences of this latest phase of
conflict in a country already facing
severe human rights humanitarian and
economic challenges as a result of the
military coup of October 2021 Ireland
condemns all attacks on local and
international humanitarian personnel and
humanitarian assets the targeting of
health workers lawyers journalists
Community organizers and human rights
Defenders as well as reprisals against
civilians who urge an end to the war or
refuse to support attainment of military
objectives must end their work is
critical to both the immediate and
long-term protection of human rights in
Sudan we urge the parties to facilitate
immediate and unconditional humanitarian
access and protection in line with
obligations under international law with
fighting concentrated in urban areas and
use of explosive and aerial Weaponry IDP
settlements hospitals schools and vital
civilian infrastructure have all been
the target of attack UNICEF reports that
seven children are killed or injured
each hour hundreds of thousands have
been displaced the work of Ohr and the
designated expert are vital to both
preventing and ensuring accountability
for human rights violations Ireland
supports the strengthening of monitoring
and Reporting we call on this Council to
speak with the United voice against this
Reckless violence and in solidarity with
the Sudanese people and their demands
for peaceful and Democratic future I
thank you thank you Italy
Mr President Italy aligns itself with
the statement of the European Union
Italy is deeply concerned about the
deterioration of the human rights
situation in Sudan following the
outbreak of hostilities on 15 April
which have already caused a death toll
of hundreds and thousands of uninjured
we also we are also Gravely concerned
about the exacerbation of the already
dire humanitarian situation in the
country as well as the sharp increase of
internally displaced persons and
refugees in neighboring countries Italy
calls on All actors involved to
immediately end the armed confrontations
protect civilians and refrain from
attacks on civilian infrastructures
including medical and education
facilities as well to enable rape Rapid
Safe and unhindered humanitarian access
Italy welcomes and supports all
mediation efforts including by the UN
the African Union I got and the league
of Arab states to achieve a lasting
ceasefire and resume an inclusive
political dialogue with a view to
establishing a transitional civilian
government we also appreciate the joint
initiative by the U.S and Saudi Arabia
that led to preliminary talks in Jeddah
between representative of the Sudanese
armed forces and the rapid support
forces Italy stands in solidarity with
the people of Sudan whose aspirations
for a peaceful and Democratic future
deserve the full support of the
International Community I thank you Mr
President
thank you Israel behind the floor
Mr President Israel is concerned over
the recent events in Sudan and the
implications of the ongoing hostilities
which began on 15 April 2023
Israel calls on all parties to show
restraint and to refrain from attacks on
the civilian population in addition
Israel calls on all parties to return to
the path of internal reconciliation in
order to conclude the process of
governmental transition with the white
consensus
Mr President since fighting erupted in
the country Israel has been operating
via virus various channels to which a
permanent ceasefire and welcomes several
ceasefire agreements rich in the last
few weeks Israel urges all parties to
respect them and reach a peaceful
solution I thank you
thank you and now let me invite New
Zealand
Mr President New Zealand is deeply
concerned by the alarming human rights
situation in Sudan the many hundreds
killed thousands wounded and hundreds of
thousands displaced our Grim testimony
to the toe the conflict has already
taken on the people of Sudan but these
numbers tell only part of the story the
destruction wrought by the fighting has
thrown the population into a
humanitarian crisis stands in the way of
Sudan's transition to democracy and
imperils the human rights of the
Sudanese people
New Zealand urges the parties to the
conflict to negotiate and adhere to a
ceasefire to alleviate human suffering
particularly by allowing excess for
humanitarian Aid and with a view to
agreeing a long-term negotiated peaceful
settlement enabling the transition to
civilian-led government Mr President
reports of human rights violations and
abuses by the combatants to the conflict
including reports of sexual and
gender-based violence are deeply
disturbing is it is therefore entirely
appropriate that the Human Rights
Council is holding this special session
New Zealand supports the resolution
which enhances the existing Mandate of
the high Commissioners designated expert
on human rights in the Sudan and is
complementary to other International and
Regional efforts towards peace in Sudan
we urge all council members to support
its adoption thank you Mr President
thank you and now let me invite Egypt
Mr President my delegation aligns itself
with the statements of the Arab and
African groups and our national capacity
would like to expect Express Egypt's
solidarity with the brotherly Sudanese
people with whom we have historical
relations as a neighboring state Egypt
is attached to stabilizing the political
and security situation and to respond
quickly to the humanitarian needs in the
Sudan and therefore we stress the need
for an immediate and comprehensive
ceasefire in order to preserve the
wealth of the brothers Sudanese people
and institutions of the Sudanese State
we are making strenuous efforts to
facilitate the arrival of people from
Sudan through border crossings and to
provide them with humanitarian
assistance and necessary Medical
Services we urge all International
organizations and U.N agencies working
in the humanitarian field to redouble
their efforts and to provide necessary
assistance to alleviate the suffering of
the Sudanese people which is this
opportunity to reaffirm our principal
position rejecting the convening of
Council meetings on the human rights
situation and states the establishment
of mechanisms to follow up the situation
or to expand the men date of the
mechanisms already in place without the
consent of the country concerned
especially if this country is already
cooperating with the council and its
various mechanisms thank you Mr
President
I thank you and I'm inviting Slovenia
thank you Mr President Slovenia aligns
itself with the EU statement we are
deeply concerned by the human rights
situation in Sudan for decades Sudan has
provided shelter for internally
displaced persons as well as for
refugees from the region despite
conflicts in some parts of the country a
significant part remained peaceful
following the outbreak of hostilities
since 15 April 2023 many civilians have
been killed injured or displaced
civilian infrastructure has been
destroyed the ongoing fighting between
the Sudanese Armed Force and the rapid
support forces threatens the Safety and
Security of people of Sudan and
undermines the transition towards the
civilian-led transitional government
we condemn any attacks on humanitarian
workers and Civil Society organizations
and call on all parties to the conflict
to comply with their obligations under
international law including
international human rights law and
international humanitarian law we call
on parties to the conflict to
immediately cease hostilities without
preconditions and to work on a political
solution to end the ongoing conflict I
thank you
thank you Iraq is the next
race
Iraq aligns with the statement by the
Arab group
and the statements of the regional and
political groups it belongs to
we are concerned about the evolving
situation in Sudan and we express our
solidarity with the people of Sudan
president Iraq reiterates its Prince its
position of principle that there needs
to be an immediate ceasefire
and that there needs to be a delivery of
humanitarian Aid we support Arab
initiatives to encourage both sides to
the conflict to relaunch dialogue
to put an end to this dangerous crisis
and to prevent any escalation so that
the Paramount interest of the people of
Sudan can Prevail in conclusion Iraq
expresses its support for the
territorial Integrity of Sudan
and warns against any foreign
Intervention which could destabilize the
region
and we call for a rejection of violence
to protect civilian life I thank you
thank you and now I would like to invite
Zimbabwe
Joe's with the African group statement
like others who have spoken before us we
express our full solidarity with the
people of Sudan at this extremely
challenging time we deplore the loss of
life and the wanton destruction of
critical infrastructure our Collective
primary a priority Mr President must be
to end the fighting and to ensure secure
Pathways for the immediate delivery of
humanitarian assistance with regard to
ongoing mediation efforts we stress that
due regards should be given to the
principle of subsidiarity and in this
regard we are fully supportive of
regional mediation efforts by egand the
league of Arab states supported by the
African Union prioritizing human life
the print the Primacy of a ceasefire and
the restoration of lasting peace in
Sudan we welcome ongoing negotiations in
Jeddah in this direction we call for the
mobilization of urgent humanitarian
assistance especially for the internally
displaced for refugees and indeed for
all vulnerable groups with regard to the
resolution before us Mr President we
reiterate our concern at the
multiplicity of Human Rights initiatives
and the continued resort to Country
specific resolutions without the consent
of the country concerned
ignoring or overriding the position of
the country concerned already deeply
engaged with existing HR mandates and
mechanisms may prove unhelpful
and may actually serve to undermine the
effectiveness of this Council in the
Fulfillment of its mandate I thank you
sir
I thank you and now let me invite Saudi
Arabia
energy
the Republic
an and its brotherly people are going
through an unprecedented crisis
we in Saudi Arabia are at this side and
we wish to see peace achieved we call
for calm and restraint
while the dialogue is ongoing and we
hope that there will be wisdom
and that there will be a peaceful
dialogue
to reach stability economic recovery and
prosperity
following this conflict talks began on
the 6th of May in Jeddah
to strengthen International solidarity
by undertaking efforts with the United
States
and others and the Troika
we welcome these these measures
to achieve an immediate ceasefire
and to enable deliveries of humanitarian
Aid
in order to restore peace and Security
in Sudan
we believe this is the only way
as other ways would only complicate the
situation further
president my country reaffirms the need
to address the humanitarian situation in
Sudan
and to protect humanitarian Aid
to provide for secure corridors
for humanitarian Aid workers
and to evacuate civilians we have worked
towards
evacuating more than 8 000 people of 110
nationalities
Iran have the floor
Mr President the Islamic Republic of
Iran betrays its fundamental position on
the necessity of respecting National
sovereignty territorial integrity and
non-interference in Internal Affairs of
countries as the important principles of
international law which should which
should be taken into account in
fulfilling the Mandate of the Human
Rights Council we believe strongly that
the excessive use of holding special
session against developing countries
undermine the provisions of the
resolution 60-20 and 51 200 and 51 which
emphasizes on the principle of
non-selectivity objectivity and
impartiality as well as on the genuine
dialect and cooperation as the main
basis of promotion and protection of
Human Rights and is strengthening the
capacity of member states to comply with
the human rights obligations
human rights issues and the council
should not be instrumentalized as a tool
of some powers for advancing their
political agenda and means of pressure
on Estates and manipulating manipulating
manipulating their internal developments
it's regretful that in this case some
foreign parties seek to play a
destructive role by In Time by inciting
and intensifying the crisis
holding this special session is part of
this negative interventions and will not
bring any achievement for parties and
people of Sudan we emphasize that the
only solution as a student is dialogue
based on internal initiatives bearing
this in mind we call on internal parties
to stop immediately the military
conference confrontation and look
forward the peaceful solution through
dialect I thank you thank you and I'm
inviting Russian Federation
President we are closely following
developments in Sudan we note a
deterioration of the humanitarian
situation a shortage of food and
medication in many regions of the
country we call on the parties to the
conflict to show political will and to
take prompt steps towards a ceasefire we
believe that any disagreements can be
settled only at the negotiating table
following the end to the armed conflict
practical steps must be taken to to
re-establish the inter-sudanese dialogue
to ensure that this is inclusive it is
important in our belief that this
process involve all of the ethnic and
religious groups of Sudan as well as
prominent Regional leaders
we believe that
progress in this area would be enabled
by
achieving a broad National consensus
Russia consistently opposes the
politicization of the topic of Sudan in
the HRC playing up this topic in the
council is counterproductive and in fact
does not facilitate the settlement of
the crisis in the country
foreign imposition on the Sudanese
leadership of dubious socio-economic
Solutions and Universal democratizing
templates
and also the politicization of Economic
and financial assistance are
unacceptable we are convinced that the
people of Sudan can and must
independently resolve domestic problems
the International Community and the HRC
must provide all assistance in this
regard thank you mean right Norway
thank you Mr president president as part
of the core group Norway welcomes this
special session and as others here today
we strongly condemn the ongoing violence
and urge the competence to agree and
adhere to ceasefire immediately the
fighting must stop now
the situation for the civilian
population is catastrophic with enormous
Unitarian needs and Grave human rights
violation women and children are again
likely to pay the heaviest price
we therefore call on the parties to
urgently take measures to fulfill their
obligations under International
humanitarian law and protect all
civilians including children and
humanitarian and health workers the
parties must allow and facilitate safe
unimpended access to humanitarian
assistance without delay
Norway supports all efforts aimed at
de-escalating resolving situation and
responding to humanitarian needs We
Stand firmly behind the efforts of the
Sudanese people to establish a
democratic and peaceful future
there needs to be a resumption of the
political process through dialogue and
negotiations towards the establishment
of an inclusive Democratic transitional
civilian-led government I thank you
thank you and let me invite Libya
is
we align with the statement of the app
group and the Africa group we reiterate
our solidarity with the Fraternal
country of Sudan
in these difficult circumstances and we
stress the importance of upholding the
sovereignty and Independence of Sudan
and it is also important to reach a
ceasefire
and enable the delivery of humanitarian
Aid to alleviate civilian suffering we
support Regional efforts to achieve a
ceasefire
and return the country to the path of a
political settlement to re-establish
stability and the democratic transition
the U.S and Saudi initiative
which has led to talks currently ongoing
in Jeddah is welcomed
President we support the state of Sudan
and we call on you to respect this
country's position that it expressed
regarding the holding of this session
and on the possibility of creating
further mechanisms
part of myriad International mechanisms
on the human rights situation in Sudan
this complicates the work of these
mechanisms and limits their
effectiveness in conclusion we call on
the High Commissioner to continue
providing technical support to Sudan to
allow for promotion and protection of
Human Rights
thank you president the delegation of
Chad
aligns with the statement made by the
Africa group
as a neighboring country
Chad wishes to State its full solidarity
with Sudan in this
terrible trial
president the Secretary General of the
United Nations
highlighted that this crisis must not
spill over beyond the borders of Sudan
and that it must not threaten Democratic
Transitions and the peace process peace
processes ongoing in neighboring
countries we welcome this position
while reaffirming our commitment to the
principle of subsidarity our country
does not favor any parallel initiative
any unilateral initiative
which could stimi current initiatives
which are underway
Chad
also stresses that the human rights
situation in Sudan is already inscribed
in the agenda of the 53rd session of the
Human Rights Council
to be held in June
Chad therefore believes that priority
should be given to achieving a ceasefire
which can enable the deployment of
humanitarian assistance and stop the
mass displacement of populations which
has an impact on immediate Neighbors
all of our prayers are with our brothers
and sisters in Sudan I thank you
I thank you sir and I give the floor to
Niger
thank you president
Niger aligns with the statement made by
Cote d'Ivoire on behalf of the Africa
group and wishes to make the following
comments in its National capacity Niche
reaffirms its strong commitment to Human
Rights and its opposition to any attack
on the sanctity of the human person
however in this case we very much
question the effectiveness of the human
right the special session in the Human
Rights Council to discuss the current
situation in Sudan
my delegation particularly fears that
this session might have a negative
impact on the ongoing process which
seeks a return of peace and on efforts
by Sudan to operate with human rights
mechanisms that already exist
this is an indispensable condition for
Effective management of the humanitarian
situation and for better protection of
Human Rights above all
my delegation also highlights a lack of
Prior and transparent consultations with
the African group of which we are
president and which we have witnessed up
close
finally Nigeria reiterates its support
for initiatives by igad
and by the African Union and the Jeddah
process led by Saudi Arabia and the
United States and others
to help Sudan come out of this crisis
situation and we call on other members
of the International Community to assist
in achieving a speedy and Lasting
ceasefire and to open up humanitarian
Aid
foreign thank you president
the crisis situation in Sudan requires a
speedy settlement of the conflict to put
an end to violence restore order and
ensure security and safety for civilians
the delegation of Sudan has expressed
its position on holding a special
session ignoring this position
there's testimony to A continuing
practice in the Council of imposing
politically motivated Solutions
against the will of the
the concerned Sovereign countries we
call on countries to refrain from
actions which may have a negative impact
on the negotiation process
and to prevent
escalation and
settle the situation in the country we
support into Sudanese dialogue and
stability in this country and also
a speedy solving of humanitarian
problems I thank you Nigeria you are the
next
thank you Mr President Nigeria aligns
with the statements delivered on behalf
of the African group and that of the
government of Sudan supposedly conveying
of a special session by this Council on
the human rights situation in Sudan we
strongly concerned condemn the Watson
violence and killing of innocent
civilians including children however the
call for this special session is a
flagrant disregard of the sovereignty
and political independence of Sudan and
indeed an outright dismissal of the
efforts and commitment of the African
Union I got U.N security Council and
other Regional mediation efforts to
ensure a lot since this fire
that the very decision by some member
states to convene this special session
without request to ongoing Continental
efforts is obstructive we have to view
the actions such as this only on the
main Continental mediation efforts
including the robust engagement of Saudi
Arabia and UAE the delegation of Nigeria
remain Resolute that regardless of the
alliances on nomenclature any attempt to
interfere in the internal politics of
Sudan through the creation of another
human rights mandatory mechanism is
counterproductive and should neither be
encouraged or find room in this within
this Council while recalling the
principles of complementarity and
subsidiarity World numeric cancer to
support the government of Sudan in its
effort to achieve a peaceful resolution
to the conflict by opposing any decision
actions that could complicate the
already same situation in the country we
therefore call on member states of this
extreme Council to support the ongoing
efforts to return students with
transition process and constitutional
order and to ensure unfettered access to
humanitarian assistance and relief I
thank you
thank you and now let me give the floor
to Turkey
Mr President we follow the ongoing
clashes with deep concern International
Community cannot let the clashes turn
into a protracted conflict with severe
consequences for the people of Sudan and
across the borders
the Turkish authorities are in close
contact with old sites for Urgent
ceasefire and dialogue
we welcome the start of pre-negotiation
talks in jittah we support the efforts
of the African Union and I got in this
process
return to the civilian rule in Sudan is
the ultimate call
therefore we appreciate the role play by
the African Union together with unitums
and he got towards the civilian-led
government
we support the calls in the resolution
to the parties for a permanent ceasefire
and negotiations at the same time we
endorse the principles of African
solutions for African problems with this
understanding we are ready to contribute
to the efforts the African Union and
other Regional organizations such as IGA
thank you
thank you and let me invite Austria
thank you Mr President Austria aligns
itself with the statement of the
European Union three and a half weeks
after fighting broke out between the
rapid support forces and the Sudanese
Armed Forces bringing fear deprivation
trauma and suffering to civilians the
human rights situation in Sudan
continues to
deteriorate dramatically Austria notes
with great concern the escalating
violence and attacks on civilians
including widespread sexual and
gender-based violence in Sudan women and
girls are the primary victims of these
atrocities
with reports of rape sexual assault and
harassment in addition restrictions on
freedom of expression media and access
to information in Sudan are of grave
concern
journalists human rights Defenders and
Civil Society activists face threats
intimidation and censorship that prevent
them from carrying out their important
work
Austria fully supports the draft
resolution before us particularly
strengthening the designated expert on
Sudan the High Commissioner for human
rights and ohchr we call on all parties
to the conflict to immediately seize
hostilities and fighting to prevent
protect civilians and to agree and to
fully comply with and negotiate a
durable ceasefire and to respect
international human rights law and
international humanitarian law I thank
you
thank you Canada we have the floor
thank you Mr President Canada remains
deeply concerned about the deteriorating
humanitarian and human rights situation
in Sudan and calls for an immediate end
to the violence we are not only
preoccupied with this with what is
happening in urban centers but also with
what this will mean for already delicate
regions like Darfur
millions of people are in need of
humanitarian assistance hospitals and
doctors are being targeted and attacks
on communication infrastructure are
unacceptable Canada is also concerned by
The increased risk of sexual and
gender-based violence particularly for
women human rights Defenders and women
and children seeking to leave Mr
President the council has a distinct and
complementary role to play in response
to the crisis one that is coordinated
with and reinforces Regional efforts to
support the establishment of a
transitional and civilian-led government
we welcome the draft resolution in
particular its proposal to provide
additional resources for the office of
the High Commissioner for human rights
to respond to the situation there can be
no enduring peace and Security in Sudan
without respect for all human rights any
settlement must ensure that the voices
of local Civil Society heard and
integrated including political groups
peace Builders and a vibrant press
Canada will continue to support the
people of Sudan in their call for a
return to a peaceful and civilian-led
transition and their aspirations for
Freedom peace and Justice thank you
thank you and the next on my list is
Mauritania
thank you president
my delegation aligns itself with the
statements made on behalf of the Arab
and Africa groups and we reaffirm our
commitment to the sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
Integrity of Sudan we also reiterate our
Firm support for the Sudanese people in
these difficult circumstances we are
following with great concern the
situation in the sister Republic of
Sudan as well as the serious security
escalation and its impact on lives of
citizens and the country's stability we
call on all parties to show restraint to
give priority to dialogue and to take
into account the best interests of the
Sudanese people we of the view that the
priorities should be to promote dialogue
in order to reach a ceasefire to put an
end to the conflict and tackle the
DraStic humanitarian situation on the
ground in this respect we commend the
pre-negotiations in Jeddah supported by
Saudi Arabia and the United States and
the regional mediation efforts led by
iget and the African Union we also
therefore believe that the convening of
a special session of this human council
could
undermine these ongoing efforts
that my delegation would like to
reiterate that assistance should be
provided to Sudan so it's overcome the
difficulties and support should be lent
to the ongoing mediation efforts in
order to reach political settlement
thank you please
foreign
has taken note of the report on the
current crisis in Sudan and aligns
itself with the statement of the African
group
we have been closely monitoring the
situation of the ongoing crisis in the
sisterly country Sudan
Mr President despite the challenges
Sudan going through
and in line with the principles of
solutions to the problems in Africa
South Sudan believed that African
Solutions remain better options to
African problems and given the
historical ties between Sudan and South
Sudan we have been working closely to
poster and mediate peaceful political
settlements with each other countries
South Sudan supports the igad initiative
whereby the egot heads of the state and
government delegated on 16th of April
2023 his Excellency president sulfur Kim
Hadid and his Kenyan and Djibouti
counterparts to consult with Sudanese
leaders on the agency of arresting the
current situation in the Switzerland
country Sudan Mr President in light of
the political initiative of egot
supported by the African group and the
ongoing negotiations started in Jeddah
under the auspices of Saudi Arabia and
United States of America South Sudan
calls on the Human Rights Council to
consider lifting the unjustified impulse
human rights resolutions on so thank you
and we will continue with Tanzania
Tanzania you have the floor
thank you Mr President for giving me the
flow the United Republic of Tanzania
aligns itself with the statement made by
the by Cote d'Ivoire on behalf of the
African group We join hence in
expressing our solidarity with the Sudan
and recommend the ongoing mediation by
the region to ensure that an amicable
solution is reached and the peace
prevails we further encourage the
International Community to complement
the efforts by Sudan to protect and
promote human rights and provide the
needed humanitarian assistance
we also encourage continued cooperation
between Sudan and the office of the High
Commissioner for human rights and other
U.N agencies I thank you Mr President
for the opportunity
I thank you and I'm inviting Tunisia
chocolate inside the rice
thank you press
nizia is closely following the situation
in Sudan and we would like to express
our concern about the security situation
and its impact on the political process
we iterate our solidarity with the
Sudanese people in this difficult
situation and of course we urge everyone
to stop the escalation and to return to
a course of wisdom and dialogue so as to
reach a political settlement all this
with a view to strengthening Sudan's
stability and to helping its people we
do of course pay tribute to the efforts
made at the international and Regional
levels and the negotiations in Jeddah so
as to give top priority to Aces fire and
resume the political process
with Sudanese ownership of that process
we
would like to underscore the need to
preserve the sovereignty territorial
Integrity of Sudan and to ensure
non-interference in domestic affairs we
also pay tribute to Sudan's cooperation
with the council thank you president
thank you and the last Observer State on
my list is Uganda
Uganda you have the floor
thank you
thank you chair
Uganda aligns with the African group
statement
as a country in the region Uganda has
continued to follow the unfortunate
events in the Sudan with King interest
both at the regional and a bilateral
level
we remain concerned of the deteriorating
situation in the country in particular
the loss of life and destruction of
property this situation is not only
creating a humanitarian crisis but also
has far-reaching implications for
regional peace and security
chair the eager region has taken
necessary steps to address the current
situation the leaders have agreed on a
mechanism of Engagement with the Sudan
leadership
and we urge the International Community
to support the regional efforts to
realize peace security and stability in
the Sudan
wish to Echo The Call by igad for an
immediate and unconditional cessation of
hostilities
discolored tensions and allow unfettered
humanitarian access
the most critical issue to date in our
view is an immediate cessation of
hostilities whereas the council is
rightfully concerned with the human
rights situation in the Sudan the
question that begs is how this specific
session will realize its purpose without
an immediate end to the fighting
therefore it is essential that this
cancer works cooperatively with the
Sudan as a country of concern to
successfully achieve the tenets of the
resolution under consideration today I
thank you chair
thank you very much and I recognize the
request for the floor from the
Equatorial Guinea sir you have the floor
gracias
thank you president
speakers
you didn't actually register yourself to
a list of speakers so I gave you floor
because you waved your flag
I announced 15 minutes after the
beginning of the session then the list
of speakers is closed and you are not on
the list of speakers
so I don't know what you're asking for
eign
well I do apologize and I would be
grateful if I could make a statement
so let me ask the council if there are
any objections to
that
I don't see any objections so you have
the floor sir
gracias
the delegation of Equatorial Guinea
aligns itself with the statement by the
Africa group Ecuadorian Guinea is deeply
concerned by the conflict
between Sudanese Brothers
a conflict which has already cost the
lives of innocent
people with more than 500 deaths and
hundreds of wounded thousands of
displaced persons it has destroyed
infrastructure
thus worsening the poverty and hunger of
the civilian population our country
Equatorial Guinea has always advocated
for dialogue and understanding as ways
out of a conflict so as to ensure
genuine political stability and peace we
believe that the United Nations should
better exercise its role so as to put an
end
to
forceful seizures of power which
cast aside the will of the population
Equatorial Guinea stands by the
brotherly population of Sudan and at the
same time we call for the end to this
deadly conflict
this conflict in which the civilian
population is
always the victim we commend the United
Nations efforts
split your time and we will now continue
with the list of speakers for National
human rights institutions and
non-governmental organizations and the
first speaker on my list is east and
Horn of Africa immunized Defenders
project you have the floor
again East and Hall of Africa human
rights Defenders project you have the
floor otherwise we will skip you in
Sudanese activists and human rights
Defenders including lawyers and the
youth resistance committees which have
been at the Forefront of supporting
civilians during the ongoing conflicts
the events unfolding today in Sudan are
a direct result of ongoing impunity for
Greg
human rights abuses at the expense of
the Sudanese people and their right to
life and self-determination we call for
an immediate end to the fighting and for
the International Community to support
Sudan through humanitarian Aid the
establishments of an investigative
mechanism and for the continued support
of the Sudanese Civil Society in
transiting to a civilian-led democracy
I do apologize to the council but I'm
being informed that we need to sort out
a technical problem and we will start
again with East and Horn of Africa human
rights Defenders project please
Mr commissioner once again the council
is force it to address Sudan
the situation is dire the absolute
priority is ceasefire delivery of eight
restoration of medical care and
humanitarian corridors while the message
holding this special session
stands important the draft resolution is
not entirely satisfying we retrace the
NGO call for an investigative mechanism
until accessing the country is
reasonably safe experts will have to
rally on remote monitoring and other
roles the criminal accountability
standard used by judicial mechanisms
it's hard to reach but political and
moral accountability can deter violation
and prevent reoccurrence we hope Mr
President impunity allowed this to
happen and systematic violation to
continue without accountability violence
will recall up to 15th April there was
no real incentives on political actors
to refrain from using violence and no
prioritizing of accountability African
bodies and International Community must
do their utmost to help with Democratic
forces hold those responsible for
encrypting this misery on the Sudanese
people criminally accountable I thank
you
thank you colleagues this was the East
and one of Africa criminals Defenders
project and we will continue now with a
video intervention by International Bar
Association
students the international ball
association's human rights institutes
welcomed the special session we remain
Gravely concerned over the conflicts in
Sudan and the complete disregard of
international humanitarian and human
rights law by the Sudanese armed forces
and the rapid support forces we condemn
then discriminate killing of civilians
and the targeting of hospitals rendering
70 of them inoperable we are greatly
concerned by the exacerbation of
existing human rights violations
especially the increased reports of
sexual agenda-based violence and the
breakdown of the rule of law across the
country with civilians having to fend
for themselves with the collapse of
existing infrastructure institutions and
support mechanisms there have been
reports of uniformed soldiers displacing
civilians from their homes and using
civilian areas as Shields against
military attacks we highlight the
immense difficulty experienced by
Sudanese Nationals attempting to clear
the conflict including the exceptionally
high prices to leave the country and the
lack of coordinated evacuation efforts
we commend Sudanese activists and human
rights Defenders including lawyers and
the youth resistance committees which
have been at the Forefront of supporting
civilians during the ongoing conflicts
the events unfolding today in Sudan are
a direct result of ongoing impunity for
grave human rights abuses at the expense
of the Sudanese people and their right
to life and self-determination we call
for an immediate end to the fighting and
for the International Community to
support Sudan through humanitarian Aid
the establishments of an investigative
mechanism and for the continued support
of the Sudanese Civil Society in
transitioning to a civilian-led
democracy
and the next video will be delivered by
international service for human rights
this activists and volunteers leading
the response to the great humanitarian
crisis despite the eminent threat to
their safety and lives including false
accusation of treason threats for both
parties in the conflict assassination
list and Smith campaigns against
Defender including women and children
since the start of the war hundreds were
killed and thousands injured and missing
including women and children at least
four women medical workers were killed
the exchange of fire between the two
parties in residential areas and in
front of Health Facilities resulted in
the killing of pregnant women on their
way to give birth and preventing women
from seeking health care and food for
their children sexual assaults by men in
uniform from both fighting parties were
reported including at least seven cases
of rape cyber security alerts are
increasing due to the rise in the hate
speech and harassment against women
activists in social media most essential
services are not working including
electricity water help care with no
sexual and reproductive health care and
support for sgbv survivors and
communication internet and banking
hindering thousands of people from
leaving her tomb displacement of tens of
thousands of women in children increases
the humanitarian crisis at the borders
we urge for an end of the war protection
of civilians including activists open
humanitarian corridors protection of
women from sgpv establishment of an
international investigation I didn't
now in personal intervention from or by
International Federation for human
rights leagues via the floor
fidh AC JPS and SHRM welcome the holding
of this special session the violence
between the saf and the rsf has resulted
in the deaths of over 530 civilians
thousands injured or subjected to sexual
violence and close to a million
displaced Millions more are suffering in
the resulting humanitarian crisis with
the targeting of Civilian infrastructure
creating dire food shortages and
blocking access to even the most
essential of services
health facilities and medical personnel
have been targeted in violation of
international humanitarian law while
escalating inter-tribal tensions in West
Darfur risk compounding the effects of
the wider conflict an immediate
sustainable ceasefire is an essential
first step in resolving this conflict
restrictions on freedom of movement and
expression and on access to information
have severely obstructed Civic space
human rights Defenders have been
targeted with death threats and violence
while women hrds face particular risks
of sexual and gender-based violence we
unequivocally condemn the targeting of
Civil Society who work in precarious
conditions at Great personal risk to
carry out essential human rights and
humanitarian work
the legacy of impunity in Sudan has gone
hand in hand with continued instability
and conflict lasting peace cannot be
achieved without accountability for all
perpetrators of human rights violations
and justice for victims we reiterate the
call of over 100 Civil Society
organizations to establish an
independent investigative mechanism as a
well-established tool in the prevention
of future human rights violations
accountability cannot be delayed the
time for statements has long passed we
call on states to fulfill their
responsibilities as members of the Human
Rights Council and take urgent concrete
action to protect the right the human
rights of the people of Sudan thank you
thank you and the next speaker is Human
Rights Watch
Mr President the last four weeks have
shown all too starkly the brutal
disregard of the parties to the conflict
in Sudan for the lives of civilians
they've used heavy weapons in heavily
populated urban areas and attacked and
bombed critical infrastructure including
water systems and hospitals that
civilians who cannot flee need for their
survival hundreds of civilians have been
killed and wounded hundreds of thousands
have fled their homes often at Great
cost many remain stranded at Sudan's
borders
today we are partly here due to the
global failure to address Decades of
security Force abuses in Sudan impunity
for atrocities by both the Sudanese Army
and the rapid support forces underpins
the current crisis
in the world's wishful thinking that
Sudan was on the right path
accountability has repeatedly been
sidelined this crisis should have set
off alarms that the international
approach was not working and that
decisive action is needed to address the
impunity that has only emboldened
Sudan's warring actors in this context
we're dismayed by the collective failure
to use this session to establish an
independent mechanism to advance
accountability which over a hundred
Sudanese Regional and international
Civil Society organizations have called
for a failure that should be corrected
when the council reconvenes in a few
weeks in the meantime we look forward to
enhanced monitoring and public reporting
by the office and designated experts and
hope they will provide guidance on
concrete steps that need to be taken to
prevent further abuses protect human
rights and Advance accountability thank
you
thank you and now World organization
Against torture
Mr President the omct the Giza group and
the human rights herb remain concerned
by the ongoing conflicts related to
gross human rights violations in Sudan
more than 400 civilians have been killed
and thousand more are displaced without
access to food Medical Care and other
basic needs many other causalities
remain unreported due to security
situation and the destruction of many
health facilities in cartoon
the situation of Human Rights Defenders
is also worrisome journalist doctors
human rights activists and several ad
workers are targeted by warring parties
and risk their life and integrity while
carrying out their duties during a
conflict refugees and Asylum Seekers
particularly fleeing towards the
Egyptian border and other Gulf Nations
including Saudi Arabia are blocked at
the borders and encourage children Sudan
via Port Sudan
nothing if nothing is done the conflict
my escalate and turn into an ethnic
conflict as it is already the case in
westafoo and Wildlife state
Mr President as we have constantly
alerted this situation is foiled by
impunity and it is urgent to establish a
U.N human right monitoring and
fat-finding Mission that will help
identifying protection gaps and fabulous
specific recommendations for
accountability and assistance program
including the protection of civilians
refugees idps and juvenile Defenders
this can only reinforce ongoing Regional
efforts and only Justice will bring
peace in Sudan thank you
thank you and we will continue with a
video statement by Christian solidarity
worldwide
terrorist
thank you Mr President military leaders
continue to systematically undermine the
prospects of a transition in Sudan as
civilians built the brand of their
actions this Council must stand
resolutely with the Sudanese people in
calling for an immediate and
unconditional release emphasizing that
attacks on civilians including human
rights Defenders medical personnel
humanitarian workers and refugees and
targeting of hospitals and places of
worship severely violate international
human rights and international
humanitarian law and amount to a war
crime which will not go unpunished on
the 17th of April the Anglican cathedral
and cartoon was seized and used as a
military base by rsf fighters who forced
42 people Sheltering there including the
Archbishop and his family to leave the
building after being physically assorted
in bahrid Evangelical Church was born
and partially burned
we urge the council to reiterate the
unviolability of religious cultural and
medical locations and any attempt
to restore uh
possibility without significant civilian
involvement and the peace process will
prove unsustainable additionally a
long-term commitment by this Council to
supporting promotion protection and
fulfillment of Human Rights will prove
to be crucial in securing a lasting
peace we worked by Frontline the
International Foundation for the
protection of Human Rights Defenders
online Defenders Works to protect human
rights Defenders at risk since the
eruption of fighting on the 15th of
April human rights defenders in Sudan
are at increased risk of assassination
and have received death threats from all
parties to the conflict extremists have
publicly called for a fatwa to kill
journalists and Civil Society leaders
human rights Defenders face increasingly
dire circumstances with dwindling
supplies and unreliable access to power
the internet and banking services this
has limited their ability to carry out
their crucial work providing support to
those in need documenting human rights
violations and Reporting back to
Partners they are inherently at risk of
targeted retaliations
last week human rights Defenders
Muhammad Ahmed and Muhammad Jamal were
abducted and tortured by the Sudanese
military while providing medical
assistance
their hands were cut and their heads
shaved in an apparent attempt to
humiliate them before they were released
we call on all parties to immediately
cease hostilities and ensure human
rights Defenders can safely carry out
their work including by reinstating
secure communication channels and
banking services
we call on the Human Rights Council to
establish an international investigative
mechanism to ensure accountability for
human rights violations
now they in person intervention by
International Organization for the
elimination of all forms of racial
discrimination at the floor
thank you President we welcome the
company the convening of the special
session in response to the humanitarian
emergency of the country the numbers
reported on the ground are unequivocal
in confirming the humanitarian crisis
affecting the population as a result of
continued instability for use the utmost
urgency is to guarantee humanitarian
access no matter what in accordance with
humanitarian obligations humanitarian
access must be granted the necessary
safety to intervene we know people in
need of assistance reach more than 15
million the third of students population
and that was before the current Crisis
began we had too many wearing
testimonies of an already fragile
economy in precarious Healthcare System
now health workers also have to deal
with water shortage power outage and
lack of basic medical supplies with the
constant fear of being caught in the
crossfire as some attacks have been
directed at Health Facilities the number
of internally displaced people on
refugees was high before the conflict it
dramatically increased in the past week
we therefore ask for Urgent apparent
measures to be taken to assess the
displays and neighboring neighboring
countries in this period effort in
Geneva International Center for justice
urged all consent party that civilians
maybe must be assured a safe evacuation
from from their home and security must
be guaranteed for the Ten of thousand
that have already left we joined the
call for cessation of hostilities and
respect for the principle of
international law especially the
prohibition to Target civilians thank
you
thank you and we will continue with
Amnesty International
to President we welcome the holding of
this special session at crucial moments
since 2018 Sudanese people have staged
waves of massive protests oftentimes at
Great personal risk to demand a system
that better promotes and protects their
rights the rapid support forces and the
Sudan Armed Forces each have histories
of committing serious violations of
human rights and humanitarian law in the
country particularly in Darfur these are
forces that worked together since 2018
to crush protests and then to Stage a
coup against the country's transitional
government in October 2021. these forces
are violating International humanitarian
law again but now in their conflict with
each other as documented by us and
detailed by many speakers today causing
massive suffering for civilians
throughout the country this must end we
call on all states to open safe Pathways
and ensure protection and support for
people fleeing Sudan and to provide
prompt access to Asylum and protection
against reformal ongoing violations in
Sudan are part of a long history of
impunity and the Human Rights Council
must act with ambition and in a manner
complementary to other internet National
Regional and sub-regional efforts to
help break this cycle of impunity the
Human Rights Council should establish an
independent accountability mechanism
along the lines called for by over a
hundred Civil Society organizations this
is what is needed and what should have
happened today we urge all delegations
to support the resolution tabled as a
step in the right direction and support
establishing such an independent
accountability mechanism at the earliest
possible opportunity thank you Mr
President
thank you Association my owner for human
rights and immigration
thank you President we welcome the
convening of this special session and
express our utmost concern for the
current humorous violations such as the
killing of civilians and the
indiscriminate attacks on hospitals
taking place in Sudan
while the situation has been escalating
over the last two months we reiterate
that even before the violence began on
April 15th millions of people in Sudan
and neighboring countries were already
highly dependent on Aid
but in a third of Sudan's population is
already facing acute food insecurity and
the ongoing violence is only
exacerbating this crisis notably due to
the restricted access granted to
humanitarian workers
in addition to the crippling economic
and security crisis the people of Sudan
are subject to gross human right
violations such as arbitrary arrests and
attention unlawful attacks and killings
looting obstruction of Access to Health
Care and the first occupation of
Civilian infrastructure
Geneva International Center for justice
and Mauna call on all parties to abide
by their obligations under international
human rights law and all relevant U.N
entities to take necessary measures to
help those in need
we also note that what is happening in
Sudan is only one example of the rise of
militia and paramilitary groups in the
region worrying situations in which
powerful militias compete for and share
power with the military have already
been observed in other countries such as
Yemen and Iraq we were a Trader's stance
calling for the respect of the rule of
law and the independence of national
institutions I thank you
thank you and now we will continue with
a video video statement by Mart for
peace
development and human rights would like
to express its appreciation to the Core
group on this draft resolution
we are especially appreciative of the
Clause referencing to an enhancement of
the interactive Dialogue on the human
rights situation in Sudan to include the
participation of civil society and other
stakeholders as we believe that input
from more stakeholders on the matter
will lead to a multi-dimensional
dialogue
Mr President we however believe that
operative Clause 6 requires more details
in order to set out specific guidelines
as to how the International Community
can provide protection to vulnerable
populations in Sudan without risking the
National Security of the neighboring
member states that may offer Refuge
maths also suggests adding a clause that
calls for the Urgent establishment of a
Hybrid Court to prosecute individuals
responsible for past atrocities
regardless of their affiliation or
position in order to deter current
perpetrators from repeating these
atrocities and securing guarantees of
non-recurrence
thank you Mr President
Center for human rights in person
thank you president the increasing
reports of violence and human rights
violations in the conflict in Sudan are
extremely concerning which is why the
special session is imperative at such a
critical moment since dance history we
express our deepest concerns over the
hostilities taking place in heavily
populated areas the unlawful means of
warfare and the targeting of civilians
and civilian infrastructure this
directly violates the international
humanitarian law principles of
Distinction proportionality and
precaution enshrending customary
international law and the Geneva
conventions both which must be respected
by all parties to the conflict
we further strongly condemn the lack of
access to humanitarian NATO civilians
within Sudan we implore all parties to
open humanitarian corridors and allow
humanitarian Aid institutions to conduct
their work and for them to do so in a
safe and timely manner the International
Community must also double its efforts
to address the increasing humanitarian
situation in Sudan which will according
to the unhcr lead to a massive Exodus
therefore we call in Sudan's neighboring
countries to abide by their human rights
obligations and keep their borders open
streamlining Asylum procedures and
ensuring respect for the principle of
non-refumon finally Mission Center for
human rights and Geneva International
Center for Justice Street condemn the
ongoing hostilities and urge the parties
to return to the negotiation table
striving to de-escalate the conflict and
achieve a common and durable solution
for peace in Sudan thank you
thank you and we continue this run
contract again
senior Presidente la president rather
welcomes the organization of this
special session the third of its kind on
Sudan since the creation of this Council
for four weeks now extreme violence and
massive and serious human rights
violations in Sudan have been ongoing
and the corpses continue to pile up in
the streets of Khartoum not to mention
the number of wounded and the massive
flows of displaced persons and refugees
to neighboring countries redo firmly
condemns the ongoing Barbarian
airstrikes on the seven population and
the destruction of Housing and hospitals
and the Looting of the world food
program and other humanitarian
organizations after the genocide of
Darfur and the fall of Omar Bashir all
the hopes of the Brave Sudanese people
for democracy freedom and Justice and
the fight against impunity are doomed to
failure raddo holds the two generals
responsible for crimes killings summary
executions and extraditional killings
since the start of the crisis it is time
that the International Community
mobilizes itself to support the
political dialogue process and an
immediate military intervention in order
to protect the defenses population
moreover red or continues to be
concerned by the calls for racial hatred
as well as manifestations of racism
between different different ethnic and
tribal groups
in conclusion rato calls on all parties
to observe an immediate ceasefire and to
open up a humanitarian Corridor for
Public Health assistance and for meeting
basic needs thank you thank you and now
let me invite the broad national
movement
say the race
ladies and gentlemen
we thank you for holding this special
session
on behalf of my colleagues
I
pay tribute to the memory of Martyrs and
I call on you to put an end to this
absurd conflict which has been going on
since the 15th of April and which is a
war crime in keeping with article 8 of
the Rome statute which created the ICC
it is necessary to uphold and respect
International instruments which call for
protection of civilians
we call for
the necessary Aid to be provided to
people who need it and for humanitarian
corridors to be opened to evacuate
civilians and provide medication and
protect hospitals and places of worship
we also
cool
for the islamist movement of Sudan to be
included
on the list of terrorist organizations
that threaten International Peace and
security I thank you
thank you and now let me invite
Interfaith International
president
the breaking out of a fresh spiral of
violence in Sudan is the direct
consequence of the failure of the
transition and The Chronic impunity
enjoyed by those responsible for the
genocide in Darfur Interfaith
International and reservedly condemns
the continuing attacks on civilian
populations who are defenseless
destruction of Hospital infrastructure
Tyrion Depots and targeted attacks on
doctors U.N
ET let's do the conflict to create
conditions to open a humanitarian
Corridor and to protect Hospital
infrastructure to save human lives
Interfaith International supports the
setting up of an international
Commission of inquiry and the
appointment of an expert panel to assist
the country in preventing ethnic
cleansing in conclusion Interfaith
International fully supports the
struggle of the people of Sudan for
democracy and we reaffirm our commitment
to security sovereignty Unity
Independence and territorial Integrity
of Sudan I thank you for your attention
thank you and the institute for human
rights is the next
thank you Mr President The Institute for
human rights is very concerned about
Sudan's humanitarian situation in the
wake of the conflict that started in
mid-april of this year already the
situation with refugees and internal
displaced Spirit bill is critical
according to the U.N data the conflict
had caused approximately 700 000 people
to become internally displaced and the
incoming reports show that these figures
are dramatically increasing in which
each passing day there is a serious risk
to food Security in the country as
Supply chains are being disrupted just
recently a fire destroyed the crop
Market in yala the capital city of South
Darfur which can result in a potential
shortage of food in the region the
Health Care system is of particular
concern the Sudanese doctors Trade union
has reported that 60 out of 88 hospitals
in or near Clash zones remain closed
with 28 being threatened with closure
due to a lack of staff and essential
supplies doctors and medical workers
have been threatened and faced
repressions physical violence illegal
surveillance and trekking Institute for
human rice believes that International
Community and Human Rights Council in
particular should use all the available
mechanisms to facilitate a quick and to
hostilities and provide rapid
humanitarian assistance to the affected
population only thus a greater
humanitarian catastrophe can be averted
I thank you
thank you and now let me give the floor
to The Institute for reporters freedom
and safety
thank you Mr President Adolphus is
concerned about inconsiderable
deterioration of the human rights
situation in Sudan since 15 April 2023
an armed conflict between saf and rsf in
discriminately Target civilian
population and infrastructure resulting
in the 600 people in debt and thousands
more injured while recognizing the human
casualties as a key issues to the
promptly soft the RFS would like to
highlight that the conflict has placed
many journalists and media workers
within the country in a difficult
position further exacerbating their
challenges of their job after the
military coup in 2021 Sudanese
authorities already introduced several
restrictions of freedom of Expressions
by imposing internet blackout Banning
media outlets and press institutions
detaining beating and intimidating
numbers of Sudanese journalists the
situation with the access to information
and journal safety was worse since the
escalation of the conflict at the radio
and television headquarters were the one
of the K Target of the two parties local
and international media Representatives
report in constant threat of their lives
while performing their duties both from
the crossfire and the suspension tools
from their army groups the RFS call to
UN member states to undertake all
possible International regulative
mechanisms
to ensure listing peace and safety for
the people of Sudan thank you
thank you and the last speaker on my
list is African Center for democracy and
human rights studies you have the floor
thank you Mr President
the African Center Associates itself
with the remarks and considers expressed
by the High Commissioner for human
rights before this special session no
one knows the exact numbers of victims
civilians are military alike but all
evidence suggests that thousands of
individuals lost their lives or injured
merely due to indiscriminate aerial
bombardment and heavier artillery and we
call for immediate end of these crimes
the ongoing military confrontation
scrubs hopes and aspirations of the
Sudanese people for better life peaceful
transition to civilian governance and
enjoyment of Liberties this unfortunate
development are Bringers that peace in
Sudan is unattainable dream and that
millions of world victims in their
foreign elsewhere in the country will
continue to suffer for years to come as
a reminder Mr president Sudan has been
under the public procedure of the young
human rights for over 30 years yet we
see no change in government practices
the painful reality behind this sad
story which is yet to be addressed is
that while Sudan is an African country
and officially color blind however
racism discrimination and manipulation
of ethnic and tribal differences are at
the heart of the country's protracted
violence and political instability it is
time for Sudan to address the root
causes of armed conflicts
and it is also time for the African
Union as the International Community
at large to continue to treat the
symptoms and leave the disease uncured
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much
excellencies colleagues ladies and
gentlemen as I've indicated we have
exhausted the list of speakers
so let me thank you for your
contributions for active participation
let me thank uh to the interpreters for
allowing us actually to finish the whole
list of speakers this morning this is
the end of this morning session we will
reconvene at 3 pm to take connection on
the ground resolution a slash HRC s
36 L1
and now uh let me declare close the
first meeting of this 36 session special
session of the Human Rights Council and
let me wish you
good afternoon and see you at 3 P.M shop
thank you